there's no time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey what's going on yeah oh I didn't
even know she had that shirt on you
haven't worn that in a while I've worn
this in a while yeah
[Laughter]
so yeah born unit sure so sent this to
me yeah it was a birthday present what
I think it was a birthday you're asking
me like I would remember that kind of
stuff time doesn't mean anything it's
just a very fabulous concept when you
work from the home and you're you're
it's once you just went along [ __ ]
work today
pretty much yeah
I mean it pretty much is it's very I
mean I'm always thinking about oh what's
the next video I gotta do or what's the
next thing I gotta do it's like you know
while this [ __ ] was rolling while the
the beginning credits are rolling we
were already talking about what it is we
had to do before the New Year's
but uh maybe we're going to keep it a
secret no I don't think it's
particularly secret right I'm just I'm
just saying that I was thinking about
redoing all the um the little intros
that's all and maybe like and maybe
doing like a different slightly
different logo like variation on the
logo just kind of refreshing the channel
because it's been a while we've been
using the same some of those we've used
and also I wanted to kind of do like I
said I kind of touched on this a little
bit like in uh on the patreon post
because I was just kind of like I've
gotten so behind because of the holidays
um and because of my new channels and
stuff that I haven't really been posting
as much
um like Early Access and stuff so I want
to maybe get back to that maybe I might
do fewer videos a week but not and I'm
not going to worry about like putting
them up oh my God it has to go up on
this day or I'm just gonna put them up
when they're done you know what I mean
and not really worry about uh about that
kind of stuff and also I kind of wanted
to like streamline kind of stuff because
I feel like because remember when we
first started like for example when we
first started doing the matinee
uh you know series we started doing that
as separate from the movie retrospective
series because the movie retrospective
series was like recorded and that was
just like one a week there but he voted
on which is fine but like when we first
started doing the matinee show it was
when we were going to the theater and
then we were like filming our reactions
to the movies like right after we saw
them and so we just kind of continued it
like that even though we weren't really
doing it like that anymore and then I
was thinking the other day it's like I
kind of felt like for a while we made
the distinction oh the matinee we'll
talk about new movies and then
retrospective we'll talk about old
movies but now it's just kind of like we
just talk about whatever like whether
they're new or old like whichever one we
happen to watch so I'm like I just kind
of feel like the the distinction between
those two Series has disappeared so I
might just kind of lump everything
together into like hey it's a movie
review like new old whatever the [ __ ] we
watched because I kind of feel like I
don't make that distinction we shouldn't
make that distinction anymore so I might
just do that I mean like I said it's not
really going to make a lot of difference
to people watching it it'll just have
like a different
it'll just maybe be in a different
playlist and have like a different intro
that's all
you know what I'm saying and then some
might be live or some might be recorded
like whichever ones we do so you know
I'm just saying it's all good it's all
good I'm gonna let you handle it
I'm gonna let her hand isn't that what
always happens yeah well that's what
always happens you think about it more
than me you you know you know the data
you know the date the metrics and
everything better yeah yeah it's just
better to do it that way well and I kind
of like
in some ways I like that the channel
grew like organically and they were just
like oh we added this and we added that
but then like after a while I'm just
kind of like oh my God like all this
stuff is just so disorganized and all
over the place and it causes me great
anxiety yeah
um so I like kind of prefer things just
like hey this is a movie review hey this
is a book review you know and I have
like little different intros for each of
those things but we just did what
everybody else did though the the show
just changed with the times yeah yeah
and whatever Market forces were
dictating to us what worked we kept what
didn't work we got rid of so that's just
what everybody else does yeah because
remember we did some [ __ ] doing we did
some of the damn thing shows that were
almost like screensavers remember it's
all written with yeah relaxing music
those are cool but they didn't get
enough hits they were they were kind of
out of date when we did them that was
working a couple years before that it's
just yeah things go in and out of style
you just gotta find out and then it came
long format [ __ ] live streaming came
into style and that was the way to go
because [ __ ] we can interact now getting
super chats and the shows are a lot more
spontaneous it's less work than doing
slash I mean it's still a lot of work
but it's a lot less work than it was
slideshow was tearing her up man yeah
she spent all day just getting [ __ ]
photos
and finding photos
and cropping them and editing and
editing yeah and scrolling them out and
everything like so that was kind of like
those are cool shows but they just they
we had to change with the times you know
that's true other people were doing that
and then in that era and then they
stopped also
just because live streaming is where it
was at that's where we got the greatest
response
from yeah and we started as a [ __ ]
podcast yeah and when we started as a
podcast we got a lot of [ __ ] hits on
the podcast on Old Network we were at we
were getting like what 50 000 views or
download Monday or something about that
something yeah per episode
but there was no interaction and we
never saw a dime
so not yeah not really so it didn't
matter yeah
that's the thing YouTube was where it
was at but we kept the podcast name
yeah so that was another thing if I redo
the logo I might just take that out Take
podcast off I mean technically I still
do upload it just an audio only version
of it that goes to like various like
podbean and stuff like that like and
iTunes if people want to listen to it
just audio we could call it 13 o'clock
mystery or some [ __ ] like that 13
o'clock well I mean I kind of feel like
it should just be 13 o'clock 13 o'clock
yeah just that's what everybody knows 13
o'clock True Crime mystery some [ __ ]
like that yeah but like I said we talk
about True Crime we talk about all the
time I mean like today this is a true
crime show kind of yeah and also kind of
and honestly like this
um I already know because of this topic
this is probably gonna get demonetized I
don't know about like demonetized but
it'll for sure like be limited
advertising because a lot of advertisers
don't want to be on a video about uh
terrorism so there's that right okay but
you know what I mean I kind of have I
don't have too much trouble with a lot
of the topics but anytime like
something's like True Crime like serial
killers it's like really egregious then
sometimes you'll have like limited I
don't think I've ever hadn't had ads
taken off completely but sometimes like
there's a lot of advertisers that would
prefer not to be on shows that are about
sensitive yeah like shows that are about
like serial killers and stuff like that
which like I said I don't really care
but you know and and those [ __ ] there
were in those same [ __ ] murders were
covered on network television they'll do
whole documentaries they'll do news
reports on the [ __ ] and they'd and they
would have well that's what I'm saying
and the thing about it was that I was on
I went on YouTube and they had like
there's tons of like documentaries about
Timothy McVeigh on there because it's
them talking about it see well I mean
other people have uploaded stuff that
they recorded from like PBS or whatever
like I don't think like a couple of them
were from the official channels but a
lot of them were just people that had
taped it like back in the 90s that old
mainstream corporate format they they uh
they felt you know sanctimonious about
their [ __ ] only they could advertise on
that you know they didn't want anybody
else [ __ ]
talking about those cases it had
happened to be official
oh yeah right well like I said I kind of
feel like it's not even people
um doing it because a lot of times like
algorithm is doing it that's what I mean
so because a lot of times like I'll
watch because a lot of times for
preparations of these shows like I'll
watch other people's documentaries about
and some of them have ads and some of
them don't like it doesn't really seem
it doesn't really seem to be any logic
yeah I'm doing it but it was [ __ ]
humans that told the AI to do it see
it's just you know [ __ ] them
you know Tyler got Tyler the guy said I
hope you all touch on the third bomber
Theory that's the most interesting part
in my opinion yeah I mean we might touch
on that a little bit but I you know I
don't really know if there was one or
not yeah they were even back in the day
they thought that that some of the guys
got away well they're well the one guy
that they thought was the third guy that
they called like John Doe number two
they figured out who that guy was and it
wasn't like it was just like an innocent
okay I remember when all this happened
that just happened to be there the day
before it was like a mix-up or something
like that but I don't know like I'm you
know I'm not saying there weren't other
people involved I'm just saying that
particular guy that they thought was
John Day number two was not involved
this is a good case man because this is
kind of a monument to
to how much things have changed okay
it used to be guys thought that if you
took direct action against a political
opponent and did something like this
you'd be able to get your message out
and really because they didn't have
internet they did kind of get their
message out when they did this
but it always came back to [ __ ] haunt
you it always kind of this isn't really
where you want to deal with problems
um nowadays if you want to [ __ ] up the
government and screw up some of their
[ __ ] corrupt plans like this was this
had a lot to do with Waco okay
nowadays all you do is just start a
YouTube channel and make fun of them
they can't stand being ridiculed and
made fun of all right because they take
themselves very seriously
um and you'll do more damage to them
that way and information war and
propaganda than you would ever
destroying a concrete building and
accidentally blowing up a bunch of kids
at a daycare center yeah and a bunch of
adults too yeah not a budget so this
kind of thing
of what these guys did was it was
obsolete well the thing about it I was
thinking about this while I was like
reading I was like it's not only
monstrous and morally repugnant
obviously but it's also ineffective yeah
it's ineffective it doesn't it doesn't
achieve the desired goal it right but
yeah that's what I mean I'm not saying
I'd agree with the dude because I don't
I'm just saying that if the if
you had some views and you wanted like
to call attention to something or
whatever this ain't the way to go about
right yeah well I see the thing is I
agree with what they were mad at all
right which was
they were mad about what the ATF did to
wake up well yeah that was [ __ ] up
what they did was [ __ ] up but this
isn't how you deal with it no that's
what I mean yeah it's like you doing
that doesn't make that any less [ __ ]
up and it's not gonna you know what I
mean it's not solving anything right it
was just kind of a an out of date way of
dealing with the problems and it always
backfires on on the cause
a lot more effective now they didn't
have they didn't have internet back then
well yeah this was the 90s but like you
know mid 90s nowadays the Advent of
social media has kind of made attacks
like this obsolete
which is good because people don't die
now you can just say what you want to
say and if it's a popular belief you can
change things okay
um governments are corrupt they're
[ __ ] tyrannical they do stupid [ __ ]
because they want to get promoted and
the main the main goal of any government
is to grow it's to grow its power and to
grow its ability to make money and to
pay their friends that's really all it
is and to protect the ruling class that
keeps them in business
that's his purpose it doesn't have
anything anything to do with protecting
you or to make your life easier they
will ship your jobs overseas they'll
sacrifice you they'll throw you into the
jaws of a [ __ ] war machine to fight a
war that really only benefits guys at
the very top the whole thing is [ __ ]
crooked
um so yeah you should be able to get
that message out this is not how you do
it
you don't do it by blowing up a
government building it's just a building
they'll build another one and then
they'll take what happened and they'll
flip it around and say how how that
these people are all terrorists anybody
who disagrees with us as a terrorist
anybody that says no to us is a
terrorist bend over that's what it
becomes
so you don't want to do it this way
best way to do is just make fun of them
call about for what they do make fun of
a ridicule and they can't stand that
that really hurts their butts they get
butt hurt
because they come out of these
institutions they feel very serious
about themselves and their Authority
they're just there's other losers you
know
[Laughter]
government bureaucrats are the [ __ ] they
can't survive in the [ __ ] real world
they're the rich kid flunkies
come out of universities give these
paper pushing jobs and those skills to
speak of no Talent uh they're just
[ __ ] pressing buttons and filling out
[ __ ] paperwork and telling other
people what to do and trying to expand
their department and make sure that the
budget is fulfilled I know I was there
you know they're nothing to this
but uh this is not how you fight them
fight them in law and courts and the
court of public opinion that's how you
do it voting
that's all I'm saying oh okay wasn't
sure I'm never sure when you're done no
I'm sitting here you should feel time
man you should probably you should
probably like do like on the CB and be
like you know and say when you're done
yeah so I know
what's up Dave uh he's here he says my
shop sells machetes axes tarps and
shovels serial Psycho Killer supply
store see there you go well you know
you're gonna get flagged
too late so like we already yeah I
already like um I wanted to do this
topic now
um somebody said we should do Ruby Ridge
as well because that was another one
that uh Timothy McVeigh was mad about I
think we did do a show on Waco did we
not
that we did a show about wake up but we
haven't done Ruby Ridge though because
that was another thing I mean I wanna
you know I don't want to get too much
into that but that is one thing that um
yeah that Timothy McVeigh was like he's
mad about that too bad about that too
right because they happen like not that
you know kind of close in time yeah it
was ATF stepping out the ATF trying to
justify its existence
they couldn't find any bad guys they'd
make a bad guy
a lot of the guys they were [ __ ] with
were kind of bad
but they went out of their way to make
that a violent confrontation there
wasn't there could have been a much
easier way they were trying to have a
spectacular raids and spectacular
something looked good on film so they
could justify their existence that's
that's really all it was
they didn't have to
burn down [ __ ] Waco they didn't have
to
break their way into the [ __ ] Branch
Davidian compound and [ __ ] arrested
he went into town every day all they do
just wait for him at the store and they
could have arrested him there but that's
not what they wanted they wanted a big
raid they had to justify all that
equipment and that huge budget
and that dude that they did at the
[ __ ] Ruby Ridge they had to Badger
him and he was a poor dude they had to
Badger him to make a sawed-off shotgun
so he could sell it to them for only a
couple hundred bucks so they could
arrest him and justify their existence
and he was like Ah that's illegal you
know he didn't want to do it but they
made him do it they kept [ __ ]
enticing him so what do they do show up
they shoot his dog and they shoot his
[ __ ] pregnant his wife that was while
she was carrying a baby
yeah you know just bad yeah that was
Ruby Rich yeah Ruby Rich yeah just
[ __ ]
bad way of doing it when you could have
just arrested that dude when you went
into town or something
yeah so that's what I'm saying it's like
you know obviously it's not
crazy to be mad about that because both
of those things were Monumental uh [ __ ]
shows yeah but doing what Timothy
McVeigh did was not uh not ideal no
that's not the proper response let's
let's say that it was an idea
um let's see they couldn't have foreseen
the internet though
well yeah I mean that's just kind of
like they would have been much better it
would have been much more effective
to basically made a self-printed fanzine
or a magazine or something like that
printed out on repeater graph and then
just you know or have a radio show back
in those days you could have a
radio show yeah I mean I feel like he
did have a little bit of a network in
the sense that you know he would go
around the country to like gun shows and
stuff like that and like talk to people
so there was kind of like a loose
network of people that he knew but it
wasn't like super organized or anything
like that I should have done so you
should have done something more like
that you know even though uh Alex Jones
he started on radio and he was just
pointing out inconsistencies and how
these dudes actually operate and he was
a what they call a conspiracy theorist
and then years later every all those
[ __ ] things turned out not to be
conspiracies they were real you know I
couldn't believe it
I couldn't believe it when they found
that island and and it turned out that
that [ __ ] was true he was talking about
that for years
Epstein's Island
and after that I started paying
attention but uh you know say what you
will
Bridget says Tom you're looking good
more healthy uh Jenny what's the
necklace you're wearing today uh it's a
little just a little skull with like a
little bat and a and a little black gem
on it that's what
yeah we definitely covered Waco I
thought we had yeah uh Tom Sykes said
the 80s TV show MacGyver had an episode
before this case happened that involved
box trucks with bombs in them
I think I kind of vaguely remember that
actually
yeah John Smith said these days he would
have a YouTube channel yeah exactly
right that's all you have to do
information is a far more when you look
at Warfare you know and I came up you
know in [ __ ] good military academies
and had my own military career and did
weird [ __ ] as contractors
the war is always information
information is and public opinion that's
really where the power is that's why
the CIA was so [ __ ] hell-bent on mind
control you know MK Ultra
you can't win a war until someone
believes that they're defeated if not
they just continue to fight
and if you can control their opinions
you never have to fight that fight to
begin with
so you can do this through people's
information sources of their information
the flow of information you know that
you can achieve mind control
it's known as propaganda
so uh
yeah now that propaganda is becoming and
or the flow of information is a lot more
democratized it's difficult for them to
use propaganda like they used to
um
and so that's that was mcveigh's
frustration we're gonna get into it
though
uh but he did totally the wrong thing
he wanted this big spectacular event you
know with an explosion and it would be
and everybody would hear about it and
there would be some kind of Uprising it
never goes down that way yeah it seem to
legitimately think that there would be
an uprising yeah yeah that like it never
knows him all you got to do is just look
at the other big explosions that happen
and there's no Uprising you so this is a
very old school like 1920s thinking you
know that that's not what happens you
just have to tell you what happened
before to know that he went through all
that trouble you know he's building all
that [ __ ] and spending all that money
and doing that mission and there was no
effect really not really
I mean not anything that he wanted no
yeah that's what I mean this kind of
[ __ ] is like never yeah what didn't
cause the ATF to be abolished
right you know it's like I don't I'm not
really sure like what he thought was
gonna happen like nothing he thought was
gonna happen happened no John Smith said
I thought McVeigh started off selling
the Turner Diaries at gun shows he did
yeah probably did and actually matter of
fact
um the idea for doing what he did at
Oklahoma City uh he got it like pretty
much word for word from the Turner
Diaries that's like the opening scene of
uh of that is like um you know like a
federal building that somebody blows up
like with a [ __ ] talk about if you
guys know the Turner died yeah I've got
a thing about that one I'll talk about
that like later on yeah there's nothing
to it it's uh it's [ __ ] and and what
what's talked about in general I haven't
read it but I've seen synopsis of it uh
what's in the turn of Diaries wouldn't
work that most of it wouldn't work today
you gotta edit it's very old-fashioned
it goes before social media yeah well it
was published in 1978 yeah uh by a
Neo-Nazi as a matter of fact
but it was it was about resistance
though it wasn't so much I mean it's a
it's a fictional novel but it's um kind
of a how-to kind of right in the same
way that like maybe like Anne Rand or
something like that is where she writes
like fictional novels but it's kind of
like a polemic at the same time it was
kind of like that yeah it wouldn't work
today though that kind of stuff doesn't
work
or it would be very inefficient you know
you know
no Bridget said I remember when I
learned it was an American uh Timothy
McVeigh I was in shock I was uh in the
delusion that American wouldn't do this
to their own country
Yeah well yeah
well it was against the federal
government I think what well and the
thing about it was when it first
happened uh immediately everyone thought
it was you know Islamic terrorism
because you know there had been an event
like that because you know I don't know
if people that are really young know but
the World Trade Center was bombed in
1993 yeah
um so people were still like thinking
about that as soon as they said it was
in ATF headquarters I immediately knew
it was an American well they caught him
like almost immediately yeah but they
were talking about as it was happening
though and it says oh ATF okay yeah I
know what they're mad at they're mad
over the gun bands and they're mad over
[ __ ] Waco and they're because
you know I was big into the [ __ ]
gun scene you know [ __ ] subscriptions
of the guns and ammo and those are all
real old school stuff you know and
[ __ ] uh some of the uh military and
law enforcement weapons magazines
um I was just out of the army at that
time and uh
in the gun scene the Second Amendment
scene everybody was mad about what it
what the ATF was doing and uh you know
they were there is a big argument of
whether or not it was [ __ ] kind of
constitutional what they were doing
because a lot of what they were doing
was based on laws that were passed in
the 1920s that were now moot point which
is a this has to do with suppressors and
full auto stuff and [ __ ] that really
should have been constitutional
but um
as soon as as soon as they said it was
an ATF headquarter of ATF headquarters I
was like oh okay yeah I know what this
is and then it turned out yep that's
exactly what it was it was a dumb idea
though
well it wasn't just the thing about that
building was it wasn't just ATF it had a
whole it was a whole bunch of other
stuff yeah but they didn't mention that
until later it was a whole bunch of
others yeah it was a building that had a
bunch of stuff in it but yeah it was a
bunch of different they announced it as
it was an ATF [ __ ] building which I
mean that was in there but there was a
bunch of other offices in there I don't
think McVeigh realized that there was
other stuff we'll see I thought it was
ATF
um I'm not so sure about that because I
was watching I watched a couple
documentaries about it and I was like
reading some stuff about it and McVeigh
I mean he's dead now they executed him
in 2001. but um he kind of like I don't
know if he waffled but he did kind of
like say it's like oh well I didn't know
there was like a daycare in there for
example I would have picked another
place if I'd known that however I have
seen some like kind of legitimate
sources that said uh him and his little
bro there uh Terry Nichols they actually
did a tour of the building prior to
doing it and so they knew that there was
a daycare in there and actually Terry
Nichols said later that yeah we knew
there was a daycare in there and we
didn't care well they thought that they
didn't think anybody'd be in there
because I think the timing of the attack
no it was like nine in the morning yeah
it was a Wednesday I didn't think yeah
from what I remember he said he didn't
think there'd be little kids in there
but there was because
it didn't matter they didn't look it
didn't matter because they didn't care
okay they were trying to destroy an
enemy building these are X and U.S
military guys
the units that they worked with and the
army that they were in were dropping
fire around little children going back
from the [ __ ] 19.
right well like I said that's kind of
like but he was trying to make a moral
equivalence which like I said I think
that was afterwards yeah but I'm just
saying yeah that's bad but like you
doing that doesn't make it better at the
time you know the time the military
thinking was well yeah that's children
but those are children of the enemy Let
Them Burn that's the same kind of [ __ ]
that he said right right that's but
that's what the thinking would be and
that's pretty standard for military
thinking yeah those are children but
that's the enemy's children that's not
my children burn them up
you know yeah that's kind well yeah
that's what he that's what he thought
because he said almost exactly well I'm
not that exact same yeah the same
sentiment well you know when I was in
one of the things that would happen
during raids or [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
action on the action action against the
Enemy at the objective in other words
you're inside the heart of the enemy
building
the main goal is to maximize damage and
physical trauma on the enemy
okay which people would be like well
what does that mean that means shooting
Women and Children First that means
[ __ ] making sure no one survives it's
overwhelming Force against the enemy
that's what it means anybody in that
objective is dead
once the attack is called over you go in
and see if any if there are any
survivors but they've told you to double
tap in the Kill Zone so there aren't
going to be any survivors because you
can't carry them with you you're an
Airborne unit
you know what are you gonna do drag
enemy wounded around you got another
place to attack
you can't take any prisoners these are
just
this was of course 90s and and earlier I
don't know how they are now
but back in the day
Airborne infantry and Air Assault
infantry just didn't take prisoners just
did you just read the way ambushes were
done and [ __ ] plant attacks are done
there would be no prisoners or or enemy
wounded you can't take them anywhere you
don't have the ability
you know so
and the idea is to just to terrorize and
kill and to terrorize the enemy that's
what it is you know and to make Warfare
friendlier nice you're just fooling
yourself that's not what happens not
real life
and you know Americans like to think
that we're the good guys we were never
really the good guys even going back to
World War II we were a machine gun and
German prisoners well no one's entirely
yeah that's just kind of the way yeah
cigarettes every now and then you know
some it took a lot of prisoners but
there were certain times when American
units couldn't take prisoners they'd
hand out [ __ ] cigarettes to capture
German guys let them smoke a cigarette
they didn't tell them anything and
somebody else come along with a [ __ ]
Thompson machine gun and mow them down
because you had to keep moving you
couldn't take them with you you know and
there's no way to send them back but it
depends on where they were and on those
Japanese Islands they were ordered not
to take prisoners at all going up
through those Island chains because you
couldn't take them back on the boat with
you
you know so they couldn't so it was just
liquidation
so people have to grow up about the
mentality but yeah these guys are just
they blew that building up and they of
course they admitted it they didn't
really care who was in it
if you ask me yeah later on later Ron
McVeigh said well I probably wouldn't
have knowing what I know now I probably
wouldn't have uh blown the building up I
would have gone on a campaign of
assassination against officials that's
what he did yeah that's what he said
later that he said that that he would
have done that instead I mean that was I
kind of feel like that's what he was
planning at first yeah I don't know if
he just thought it was like too hard or
too complicated too it's hard it's hard
it's complicated
but um in the grand scheme of things
that would be more that would have been
more effective probably yeah I hate to
say it but uh yeah well the thing about
it is that I don't Advocate doing that
ever I'm just saying that from a
goal-oriented standpoint blowing up a
bunch of innocent people who had nothing
to do with anything that you're mad
about is never going to be the right
solution it's a bunch of people that
aren't directly connected yeah it's like
what the [ __ ] those people are just
people that are just like working in an
office they don't know nothing about
what you're mad about and then it's uh
just a concrete building
you know so that could have been me that
could have been you that could have been
any of y'all and you destroyed a
concrete building big [ __ ] deal
nowadays the government works just all
online they're not even going to those
concrete buildings they're all just
[ __ ] working from home on their
laptops you go to Washington DC it's a
ghost town they don't go over there they
do it all from home
so now there's nowhere to attack
actually a very good security when you
think about it
there's no there's no reason for those
buildings in Washington DC anymore
I think it's kind of like safer to be
like because everyone's just kind of
like yeah they're spread out into the
like you're spread out you don't know
who's who and
um there's no paper anymore for
paperwork it's all [ __ ] Digital Data
so there's no reason for buildings those
buildings were about storing paper with
[ __ ] filing cabinets and [ __ ] [ __ ]
Xerox machines and [ __ ] that's all gone
John Smith said wouldn't he call it so
quick due to a faulty license plate or
something yeah he was speeding and I
think the cards didn't even have a
license plate and um then when he got
pulled over like he very very clearly
had um a concealed weapon yeah and he he
kind of like low-key threatened the cop
yeah so uh so yeah he got a rest and
then like later on they they'd found in
the explosion which we'll get into it a
little bit but they found like um from
the Ryder Reynolds because it was rental
truck and uh somebody at the rental
truck place like uh the rider place like
recognized him like they you know they
drew a sketch and they you know kind of
like put it together guess what what
those hams that we had for Christmas
yeah they were still on sale down there
got [ __ ] three more
did you really yes oh that's what you
one of them's a big full one the other
two were [ __ ] half a hamster okay why
do we eat that one they were only ten
dollars a ham you think I'm gonna give
up that material
a dollar Thirty a pound oh no I'm gonna
buy that [ __ ] well yeah or a dollar
twenty five dollars see that's kind of
the nice thing about like the holidays
around here is like Publix and stuff
like that there was just like please
take all the turkey take all the hams
they're free yes almost yeah so I got
actually two huge ones but it's in four
pieces and then uh I got that uh
bread flour rising down there heavy
bread flour and uh we'll make a pizza
after the show
so we get into this [ __ ] now by the
time this is over he's already planning
after I'll go out there and I'll [ __ ]
that's good because all I've had today
was like a teeny little hand sandwich
and a granola bar yeah I got two cups of
coffee calories you don't got me on I
gotta remember she's [ __ ] slimming
down like that the [ __ ] boobs are
popping on the front she's looking good
I'm gonna have to take a photograph
we're gonna do a photo shoot soon
[Laughter]
you don't want to do photo shoot you're
a ridiculous person of course I'm
ridiculous yeah you're ridiculous she
loves this [ __ ]
do a photo shoot so okay whatever yeah
uh Bridget says I'm one of those OG
listeners that listen on podcasts I
started with the Long Island serial
killer what happens a long time ago oh
man I missed most of the lives but I
always watch and like the replay well
thank you very very much yeah I mean
we like went back and forth about when
is the best time to live stream because
I know that obviously everyone's not in
the same time zone as us we're like
Eastern Standard Time because we're on
the East Coast but
you know uh so I know everybody can't
watch us live but we appreciate
everybody that drops by to see us yeah
we need to do you need to change it up
every now and then I think that way we
can catch some more I have kind of
thought about that like maybe doing like
some surprise ones or because I bet you
there's people in other time zones just
waiting to give us a [ __ ] Super Chat
well what maybe like one like one day
we're like to wake up at like four or
five hours dude okay like I did this
morning because we're getting super
chats from China and [ __ ] because
they're like oh my God we never catch
you guys live I just gotta roll out of
bed with my slippers and [ __ ] on being
like what hey what's up you guys I'm
like up with no makeup or anything yeah
nobody needs to see that oh
Bridget says I don't want to get Tom on
a tangent as yeah yeah too late uh but
what sweets did you make like I guess
like oh maybe we had uh pumpkin pies
yeah we have pumpkin pies yeah and I got
you were thinking about making cookies
but we haven't done it yet I got cookie
stuff to make we got cookie stuff we got
all kinds of cooking and then I got a
bunch of sweet potatoes that I Grew From
out in the back I was gonna make a sweet
potato pie too
because some of them are kind of
substandard they're not quite big enough
to be served as a sweet potato they're
just kind of like because I took them 30
days or out early I took them out of the
ground early when I was like man some
were big and some of them were small
I was going what the [ __ ] going on
here and then I looked into it later
said when the weather was cold because
it was later on in the season they said
let them sit in there another month or
so
that's a good so
for the temperature
I was I took them out too early for the
season but I'll know that next time you
know let them stay in there and grow
yeah you got to like keep uh keep up on
all that so the little ones that aren't
really worthy of [ __ ] serving I'll
boil them and turn them into a sweet
potato pie yeah there you go if you guys
never had sweet potato pie it's kind of
like pumpkin pie better I think it's
better
although I like them both but
same space slightly more team pumpkin
pie but sweet potato pie is good sweet
potato pie is pretty [ __ ] good well
it is yeah I'm not saying that I mean
pretty much any kind of pie is good I'll
eat so I'm not proud I'll eat pretty
much anything yeah sir you sit in front
of me honestly oh with very very few
exceptions
uh John Smith said this is my just
before bedtime drinking hot chocolate
show oh oh that's cool
uh Bridget said Jenny tell Tom I'm in
Camp Lejeune okay North Carolina okay
yeah I hear you
Linux Warrior said don't show me Jenny's
tits popping out this old man will have
a heart attack oh no we're gonna show
that we're gonna do a photo shoot it's
almost me kind of like it won't be nude
but it'll be like like a [ __ ] PR
shots for a porn star or something get
[ __ ] a lot of lag
booty see Tom's already a man I gotta
[ __ ] imagine we're gonna have a [ __ ]
sexy outfit and everything yeah I'm
gonna have to do some heavy Photoshop
[Laughter]
you haven't done a photo shoot in a
while
well yeah I know I can't remember the
last one we did because I want to do a
bane photo shoot
okay I want to do I want to do several
photo shoot do some muscle photo shoots
we'll get the [ __ ] right
I'm just gonna um but maybe like in
another six months
I'm gonna do some more stuff before that
I'm gonna I want to gain like another
three or four or five pounds somewhere
around that we're gonna see
how I look
I can do some more trend
okay all right I'ma hide
we're gonna see I think maybe I built up
a resistance to it by now
I'll see see what I feel like on Zach
says my first episode of you guys was
the one you did right after they caught
D'Angelo back in Spring 2018. first time
remember when I thought you'd been
around longer than that no it's about
when he's seemed recent but I guess it
was like no that's not recent that's
like four years ago it seems like just
the other day it was about that's what
happens when you get older that was
about the time Zach started talking and
introduced himself that's when I started
[ __ ] with him and then he couldn't
leave the show after that when I'm
[ __ ] with him
somebody I got a message like not too
long before the show that said that they
had been
um on one of our old creepy
disappearances shows yeah um I think we
talked about who's that guy um what I
think his last name was Hoagland he was
like a guy that disappeared was like
this mysterious case I think they found
that guy so
um somebody was saying oh you should
like do an update so I'm we might have
to do that you know what I mean yeah
okay Hoagland yeah not the guy that the
face on Mars guys yeah yeah this was it
no this was a guy named I think his name
was Robert Hoagland like he was like a
mysterious it was like a mysterious like
disappearance okay you know what I mean
and uh we did a show one of our creepy
disappearances because remember we would
do like I think we did four or five
volumes of those okay yeah but I think
they found him all right uh so you know
Tom is slowly turning into a white
version of the rock it says Tyler the
guy yeah
yeah I am became become vanilla gorilla
yeah yeah [ __ ] honky Carl yeah yeah
I still need to do a Honky Kong shirt I
want to do like a little Tom cartoon
like in like 8-bit if you make it I'll
[ __ ] do a shirt for it it's got to
look cool though well yeah like I said
that'll take a while later and then uh
and then a vanilla gorilla shirt would
be cool too yeah that would be funny uh
yeah because that would have to be like
a cartoon that looked kind of like
Magilla Gorilla or Grape Ape or
something right yeah yeah exactly with a
cool font something that people can read
with the gorilla on it but it would have
to look like you yeah no you can't make
it look like me
you want to because but that's like the
whole part of it don't work it won't
work well yeah with like a cartoon
version of you no that's what I mean you
see in the white version of The Rock I'm
actually according to photographs and
what people said more like Stone Cold
Steve Austin is what they've been saying
and I looked at the photograph of the
guy with it with his beard and [ __ ] and
his involved I said yeah okay that's
what you're talking about we're like
Stone Cold Steve but you have to
understand something
those dudes are like six foot [ __ ]
three six two six four they [ __ ]
they're much bigger than me
the proportions are different I'm only
five six I only weigh about 185 pounds
all right those dudes are [ __ ] way
over like 2 30 you know they're bigger
dudes you put me next to them I'd look
small
well [ __ ] when I put my super tall boots
on I'm like an inch taller than you yeah
and I'm super and I'm pretty sure right
I'm only five foot three yeah and for uh
but I have really tall boots
the only other guy that was kind of like
me was Franco Colombo he weighed 200
pounds it was Arnold's best friend he
was about five foot four 200 pounds
probably five percent body fat and he
was [ __ ] huge and he was stronger
than Arnold he could run with
refrigerators and [ __ ] like that I
wished I looked like [ __ ] Franco
Colombo
um
proportion wise I'm a little bit just
proportionally I'm a little bit bigger
than um
a little bit bigger than Vin Diesel
about like that I'm not as big as
those bodybuilders you're talking about
about like Vin Diesel I'm bigger than
Tom Hardy proportionally
um so I'm not that big
John Smith said my life ambition is to
disappear in a mysterious Way
live well like on purpose or yeah I hope
so because it's like I don't want like
something bad to happen to you and like
nobody figures it out mines work as
vanilla gorilla Honky Kong stop Tom
laugh my ass off yeah yeah that's old
man I came up with that how long ago was
that with the vanilla gorilla a long
time
Vanilla gorilla and Honky Kong I think
Honky Kong yeah
that and the abdominals abdominal
snowman that was when I was that's when
I [ __ ] had a bigger belly that was
before I started working out I called
myself an abdominal Snowman
I can tell a story about that but I'm
not going to tell us what everybody
I mean you might have sold it before but
yeah it's kind of totally it's kind of a
dirty story yeah me and Jen were in bed
together at a hotel
and and Janet Dimitri our friends
we're in the bed next to us and this is
after we were at the vampire ball the
castle in Tampa and I'm [ __ ] trying
to get it on a [ __ ] and then [ __ ] gen
Dimitri in the bed next was [ __ ]
laughing giggling and I [ __ ] I had I
had to [ __ ] a sheet around me and I
[ __ ] I'm between Jenny's legs and I
[ __ ] come up later going
laughing and [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] man
that was that was a fun night actually
how long ago was that that was like
separately that was five years ago maybe
probably yeah okay four or five years
ago yeah
yeah it's like the big vampire ball yeah
we stayed overnight at a gym Hilton or
something
Jen and Dimitri we've known them for
[ __ ] over 10 years
Dimitri is a
local DJ okay I represented him and got
him into [ __ ]
independent bar
his wife Jen is a lead singer of 13th
Angel just got long black hair and Bob
good looking girl
her she's got two daughters
one daughter they both look grown too
well they are grown yeah but you know
what I'm talking about they all look the
same age yeah they show up to the club
sometimes and they all look to be like
just a bunch of hot women hanging out
they're they're all mothers and
daughters it's ridiculous
makes you feel old as [ __ ] doesn't it
but they all look the same age yeah they
all look about like the same age they
look like they'd be friends hanging out
yeah because she has one daughter that's
21 22 and then she has one that's 18 or
19 or something like that and the older
daughter looks just like um
um
Ross I heard her last name is Ross too
uh [ __ ] Laura Laura yeah Laura Ross
with no relation between me and her but
she got the same name as me she looks
just like Laura
she does yeah
lion X Warrior four Sons I knew you and
Jenny were freaky
[ __ ] happens man I mean you know it's
well it's not like anything happened
between us and Them
it was just going on in the same room
[ __ ] we'll be me and me and [ __ ]
Dimitri high-fiving each other you know
because [ __ ] you never can't tell you
know I never can't tell what happened
especially with that much alcohol yes
yeah you know what I mean it's all
[ __ ] [ __ ] gets crazy it's like
something out of a movie
but like I said we were it was good
because it's like everybody drank a lot
but nobody was like
everybody was like in a really really
good mood but they were like really
really [ __ ] up thank you very much
thank you Bridget not much but thank you
for all your show work oh thank you very
much we appreciate all of you guys and
we appreciate anything Tyler's saying
I'm Savage thank you very much bro in a
good way yeah
all right so
um do you want to like go ahead and
start to talking about this or start
this [ __ ] off all those axes I'd like
to try three-way at least once
[Laughter]
how many women are gonna be involved in
that Zach
he's gonna say none yeah you know what
yeah I've been involved women that's
gonna say none yeah cooties
try to bring Zach on over to the dark
side
let me go to the restroom go ahead Jen
I'm gonna put some more uh want some
more ice in this yeah I'm getting kind
of melty okay
getting kind of melted and it's like not
even hot in here it's cold outside I
mean it's not well I guess it's kind of
cold outside what does it say I got my
little temperature right here it's 44
degrees Fahrenheit outside right now and
it's mostly cloudy so it's kind of cool
though it's not as cold as it was last
night but you know what I mean
I even had to put my like uh little
badger slippers on earlier because my
feet were cold
but you know I'm not going to turn the
heat on because [ __ ] that
has to be really cool for me to turn the
heat on all right so let's talk about
Timothy [ __ ] McVeigh
here's this [ __ ]
so he was born in a place called
Lockport New York
now uh he he just from everything that I
could determine they said that his
upbringing was just like completely
normal and completely boring and just
kind of like just your regular white
bread Suburban
kind of upbringing like nothing unusual
in this latest
so his parents divorced when he was
10 and he actually got brought up by his
dad in Pendleton New York
now he said
um Timothy McVeigh later said
that he got bullied in school I don't
know how what the extent of it was or
like how true that was or anything like
that
um and basically he went into a thing
because I kind of feel like he was sort
of like an introverted kid he's like
he's pretty intelligent
um I think they did an IQ test on him it
was like 126 something like that which
is not genius but it's like you know
significantly above average
so but you know he seemed kind of quiet
and I don't you know and he was kind of
like skinny a little bit I think they
called him like noodle I heard that that
was like one of his uh nicknames
so however much he got bullied I don't
know but like um if he did he apparently
or he said that he had like all these
kind of like fantasies about retaliating
against the bullies and
some people have said that maybe this is
what kind of like planted the seed
because later on he would go on to say
like when he was an adult that it's like
oh he he grew to think of like the US
government or the federal government as
like the ultimate bully kind of
situation so you know I don't know if
that's true but like I said
so um so as I mentioned as a kid they
said that he was generally like pretty
shy pretty quiet a little bit withdrawn
um but not unusual like there was
nothing weird about him like nobody
thought he was creepy or anything like
that
um apparently he only had one girlfriend
like as a teenager and
um during in one of his interviews he
just said that um he just wasn't good
with women or he didn't have any idea
how to relate to them or how to impress
them or anything like that so you know
he didn't have he had a little bit of
maybe an incel kind of vibe going on as
well
um so basically so when he gets into
high school though and you have to think
that this is like pretty early this is
early days of like computers you know
what I mean
so he actually got into kind of like
computer hacking
just like in war games if you guys saw
that movie from the early 1980s so he
has a Commodore 64 and he was able to
like hack into like government computer
systems like I said just like war games
like he didn't start a nuclear war or
anything obviously but he was able to
kind of like hack in there
and he had a um his handle was The
Wanderer which was taken from that you
know that song
so um but yeah so he was kind of like I
guess he was kind of like a computer
nerd like an early
an early iteration of that also they
said that um in high school he was voted
most talkative by his classmates uh as a
joke because he didn't talk so they
thought that would be like really funny
if they voted him that you know what I
mean
so
um his granddad actually
um kind of like started buying him guns
and like taking him out hunting and
stuff like that which you know I I was
watching a documentary earlier they were
talking to like some other people that
knew him and like lived in the
neighborhood and you know for the area
that he grew up it was kind of like it
wasn't rural rural but it was kind of
like a small town Not Unusual
um you know hunting season was like a
big deal and it's like you know father
Sons grandfathers they would all go out
hunting together and [ __ ] like that so
it wasn't like unusual for kids as soon
as they were old enough to you know know
how to use guns and go out in the woods
haunting and stuff like that so nobody
again nobody thought anything was
unusual because everyone else was doing
the same thing my dad had me shooting
the place up at about eight
Remington Nylon [ __ ] 66. a little
white diamond on it yeah that was good
with that thing
just shooting little [ __ ] pieces of
wood and cans and [ __ ] it's fun I loved
it grew up with it second nature
well yeah and it seemed like I mean
there's a lot of communities in the
particularly in this one this is
um Pendleton New York is not Upstate I'm
assuming that's upstate New York
um you know and they said that it was
very very common for yeah like kids that
it's not weird like probably shouldn't
freak people out in Europe I'm sitting
there [ __ ] throwing those little 22
rounds down the [ __ ] buttstock of
that Remington 66 and putting a thing
and [ __ ]
she
we consider them to be like a 22 we
consider that to be like a BB gun you
bought it you bought them at Sears for
like 40 bucks nothing to them right next
to the BB gun
we didn't really see any difference
between the BB gun and a 22.
they were just fun you know
uh Camp guy said didn't they execute the
other guys while Terry Nichols no he
just got life in prison but they did
execute Tim McVeigh though spoiler alert
in 2001. uh lion X says uh Jenny it's
not cold in Florida you're blessed trust
me actually I'm not complaining I really
like cold weather like well you know
it's cold for Florida 44 is cold for
Florida but I like it and I it was
actually cold on Christmas which it
hardly ever is so I got down in the 20s
I was very very excited because I was
like oh it's it feels like real real
winter it was like amazing Zach said I
never got making fun of people who were
skinny these days it seems like that's
all people want to be yeah isn't it
weird because like my brother
well I have two brothers but the one
that's four years younger than me like
when he was a little kid he was like
super super skinny and so like yeah like
my family members and stuff used to like
make fun of him and it's like oh you
better watch it when you take a shower
you're gonna slip down the drain her
because he was like so skinny and stuff
like that and I'm just like I don't know
I just think that's like really really
odd
now I just kind of feel like more
you'd think that like people would be
jealous because everyone else is like
getting so fat you know what I mean
Ben said they used to make fun of people
for being smart yeah I got made fun of
for being smart a lot
and that's it it might still be going on
I don't know but when I was in school
yeah they used to make fun of you for
being smart for sure
um let me see uh Tyler the guy said I'm
so uncultured that instead of War Games
my immediate thought was Hackers from
1995. that was a terrible [ __ ] movie
too War Games is good though I mean it's
very 80s I haven't seen that in a long
time yeah I thought it was it was
um it was for free on some streaming
service the other day and I was like oh
I kind of wanted to watch it again I've
seen it like a million times depends
like nerd yeah
um so yeah
uh the kid Timothy McVeigh uh he got
kind of shitty grades uh he graduated in
1986. so ooh that's crazy he's only four
years older than me then
yeah because I graduated in 1990.
they were my age I think yeah he's the
same age as you know yeah
so um yeah so after he graduated from
high school like I said he'd always kind
of been into guns because his granddad
and like hunting and stuff like that
but he got like really way more into it
like he was always like read magazines
about it and he got kind of like a
little bit obsessed I'm gonna say it was
like a little bit of an obsession now he
did actually go to college for a little
while but then he dropped out
and then he went to work as like a he
was like guarded an armored car like
that kind of thing and
um even his co-workers were like yeah
he's a little gun crazy you know what I
mean and even among like the guards of
like armored cars and stuff it's like
it's a little much you know what I mean
so even they were saying it was a little
much
um I'm gonna come to his defense well no
they said he came to work one day and he
had [ __ ] bandoliers on That's like
[ __ ] which I was just like yeah
that's a little why would you go to work
like that I don't know you thought well
he was the armor card driver winning
right but like that's it great but
that's not sort of like part of the
standard yeah he was trying to upgrade
all right look here's the deal
I remember those days if you were in to
uh to Firearms you could get you could
get really [ __ ]
interested in them in those days because
they were so mysterious
they they had all these Publications and
all these magazines that you could you
could uh get just at your local stores
they were using a lingo and a
terminology you really wouldn't be all
that familiar with if you if you didn't
have a proper education in them it was
like joining a scene so it took a while
to understand what it was they were
talking about like what does blowback
action mean you know what is delayed
blowback what is [ __ ] gas operation
what's what's piston operation so you
don't know what it is they're [ __ ]
talking about
and this is pre-internet so it would
take years of reading these [ __ ]
articles about these different kinds of
firearms or whatever it is they're
talking about before you were able to
put it together what the [ __ ] they were
talking about
had it been the age of the internet I
could have just Googled what this
terminology and figured it out in a
couple weeks probably
you know the rate of learning today is
much faster than it was
well [ __ ] man if you can just sit here
and say it's like oh I'd like to learn
how to do this and like literally in a
minute you can like find out how to do
that right so
back in the days that McVeigh is talking
about I was because I was kind of like
that I was like real curious about what
what this terminal what are they what is
kinetic energy how do you compute
kinetic energy what is [ __ ] ballistic
gelatin what is [ __ ] you know so all
the terminology would it took longer to
learn back then
looking back on it I don't know how we
[ __ ] did it but
it was more everything was more
mysterious it was the age of mystery
today you had to spend a lot longer yeah
like right right learning stuff and
because it took longer and it was harder
you were kind of like joining an elite
group now
you know only a few dudes knew what you
were talking about
so that's probably what he was going
through
probably although like I said
it's a little weird there were a lot of
dudes like showing up to work we'll see
and that's what I'm saying it's just
that
you know in hindsight it's really easy
to be like you know you pick up well
it's just like when we talk about serial
killers and they're just like yeah he
did this that the other thing when he
was a kid which
sometimes if you didn't know that that
person became a serial killer it
wouldn't necessarily seem all that weird
well like I said you know him being like
roll into guns and stuff like that
wasn't that unusual for the area nobody
thought anything about it really like
when he started work like at the armored
car place and they said okay him showing
up with the bandoliers that's weird yeah
that was okay like other than that like
I don't think anybody really and they
thought he was like kind of quiet but
nobody said oh my God that's a serial
killer like in training no I remember
this I remember this though
go into a Firearms range
in the 80s and in the early 90s
pre-internet
you'd show up there and all the older
guys were into sporting
rifles and sporting pistols with a lot
of wood on them a lot of Italian
shotguns and they're [ __ ] shooting
trap and [ __ ] and if you showed up with
a Norinco AK or some something that had
a military Heritage they looked at you
like why do you have that because look
at it man it's [ __ ] cool you know
look at this thing a lot more fun
so
they didn't have Shooting Sports that
were militarized
they do now
the [ __ ] that what they're talking about
he's showing up with bandoliers that
would have been satiated
okay had they had military action
shooting
events back in those days yeah because
they have it now because she would have
had more outlets right now you got guys
who are where they'll [ __ ] wear
military uniforms that match the rifle
that they have and all the carrying
equipment they'll run through a speed
course with pop-up targets they're all
being timed uh you know so they have all
these new events they're action shooting
events
and people go well that's dangerous
that's crazy well they had for forever
here in the United States they had the
same thing of cowboy actions shooting
events where you're running through a
damn course
with a [ __ ] Colts six shooters and
lever action [ __ ] carbines and double
double-barreled shotguns going through
an Old West Town you know also cool and
you're on a timer all right or you're
just quick draw events well they have
that now with modern Firearms like
military [ __ ] so had they had that back
in mcvay's time he'd have been into that
and it probably wouldn't have been as
it's not as it did it's not as it
doesn't have the Mystique or the mystery
today as it did back then because as
we've talked I think in some ways there
is some equivalent yeah because we
talked before about you don't see the
same kinds of serial killers to the same
extent that used to see them like in the
60s and 70s which was like the a day and
like I kind of feel like into the late
80s and then it started declining but
like now that we have like the internet
people can like look at like [ __ ] up
porn or you can like kind of get into
groups with other people who have the
same weird proclivities as you so nobody
feels as isolated and nobody feels like
like if you have really really strange
thoughts or really strange fetishes or
something like that you can find like a
whole community of people who are also
into that who you can talk to even if
you don't meet them in person so I kind
of feel like in a lot of ways
that's why I'm I never like you know
people are like oh the internet oh it's
so bad and everything like that I don't
think it is I think there's bad things
about it obviously just like anything
else but I think in the aggregate it's
probably been like a positive because
it's like a pressure release value
because it's a pressure release valve
and I kind of feel like had this had
Timothy no I don't know this because
it's like you'll never know because he
was one guy
um but I kind of feel like maybe had he
been born at a different time somebody
mentioned earlier you know he could have
been he would just had a YouTube show or
something like that and he could have
talked to other like-minded people and
he probably wouldn't have felt the need
yeah to do that I mean he might have
still done it anyway because people
still do do that he would have been an
online activist is what he would have
been right it had a show it had been
complaining about it and this that's
what he would have been and um same
thing with because
if you look at the United States
the way it is now it is a wash with
paramilitary equipment and weapons
the dudes that are doing these [ __ ] up
shootings they're not from that
paramilitary action scene
where they're going to those [ __ ]
ranges and doing all the [ __ ] clubs
and [ __ ] it's not them the dudes that
are doing these shootings is using some
pussy-ass kid who takes that [ __ ]
thing or buys something or they take it
from their dad or they [ __ ] buy
something they don't really know
anything about it and they go out and
[ __ ] shoot up some [ __ ] okay
that's they're not from that actions
shooting scene
but the existence of that action
shooting scene is probably releasing a
lot of pressure
yeah because people are finding a
community if you go there you can hang
out you can do [ __ ] you like to do you
can hang out with people that have the
same had you taken that nut case who did
that shoot in Reverse time and put him
in one of them clubs he probably been
all right
yeah I mean like I said you don't know
he might have still don't know
but a lot of times those dudes are
isolated and they're um they're in a bad
situation and it's a form of suicide
they're killing themselves and taking
everybody with them is what they're
doing you know another thing too was I
kind of feel like Timothy McVeigh and
one of his things was he kind of just
and I guess this happens nowadays too
but he just kind of goes further and
further down a rabbit hole and because
he was kind of introverted he only
really interacted with people who
believed the same things as him yeah so
he was in an echo so he kind of just got
like more and more radicalized yeah like
as time went on and I'm not saying that
that doesn't happen nowadays it does but
I kind of feel like it's much easier to
access like other viewpoints and stuff
it happens today and it happens kind of
with everybody it's just the thing is is
that this was a particular dude with a
particular skill set and mindset in a
particular bubble
at a particular time it was a one-off
you know there this really hadn't
happened again
um I mean yeah well the thing about it
this is still to this day still one of
the big ones
um well it's the worst domestic
terrorist attack because you said yeah
like obviously 911 but that was you know
a foreign that was uh you know
International terrorism this was this is
still the worst domestic terrorist yeah
and this happened in 1995 yeah 168
people dead yeah
we call it terrorism he wouldn't have
considered it terrorism everything is a
point of view he would have sought as
Rebellion but well yeah that's just they
all they're all like that but see yeah
that's the thing about it is that
sometimes like murderers and stuff like
that they don't call it like what it is
right yeah
well just like Obi-Wan said [ __ ] many
of the truths that we cling to depend
upon a certain point of view
and um you know it's been often said
that one person's terrorist is another
person's freedom fighter uh which there
yeah it is true uh uh a lot of the
Islamic Terror if you look at it from
their Viewpoint with their scriptures
and their cultural
uh value system
they think they're doing a good thing
yeah well the thing about it and you
know most people know this but I kind of
feel like everybody that you know you
look back in history and it's like oh
that was an evil [ __ ]
um 99 of those people thought they were
doing yeah the right thing yep that's
kind of what makes them fascinating in a
lot of ways but it's also what makes
them terrifying is because you can
really if you get in a certain headspace
you can kind of justify anything yeah
just look at mustache man and the
Germans that's what I'm saying they were
convinced that they thought it was on
their side they didn't think they were
evil no that didn't occur to them no
they're stamping out evil in their mind
right you know
that's what I mean that's what I find
fascinating about this kind of stuff is
like that kind of like uh point of view
where you can pretty much do like the
most monstrous things imaginable that
you know the major vast majority of
people on Earth would think was
monstrous but you can justify and you're
like what I'm just you know I'm doing
like a good thing over here
it's kind of you know whatever
um all right so
where was I
okay so in 1988 when Timothy McVeigh was
20 years old
um he was kind of like I said he had
some jobs here and there but he seemed
like he was kind of like uh rootless a
little bit shiftless you know what I
mean so he enlisted in the army so he
goes to basic training and uh that was
at Fort Benning
now when he was in the Army um you know
obviously he's still
uh you know was real interested in uh in
guns and Firearms you know he's in like
sniper tactics stuff like that
um Andy started getting interested in
bombs as well now he did actually get in
trouble when he was in the Army a couple
times uh for
buying some like white power merchandise
so you know what I mean
uh so there was that now Terry Nichols
who was the guy that was uh convicted as
his co-conspirator later on in the
bombing was actually his uh Platoon
guide platoon leader or something like
that but he was like so they kind of
like befriended one another because they
had like similar uh viewpoints and
similar like backgrounds and things like
that
so uh they later got transferred to uh
they were at Fort Riley that's in Kansas
so they were there together and uh that
was where the two of them met the uh
third accomplice whose name was Michael
was it Fortier or 48 now I can't
remember because I've heard it
pronounced like in the documentary but I
can't remember how they pronounced it
so uh Timothy McVeigh was actually like
a decent uh you know Army he was a
decent Soldier you know what I mean he
was a gunner and um he actually got
promoted to Sergeant
now after he got promoted
um one of the things that kind of went
around about him was that he um used the
n-word a lot
and he would usually give the black
soldiers
um shittier duties you know so he kind
of got a reputation for being a little
bit racist so got that uh got that going
for him you know what I mean
uh so yeah
so then he got uh he went to uh
Operation Desert Storm so you know he
got set down for that
now uh he says in an interview that they
did later on like after he got caught
for the Oklahoma City bombing that he
said
um on the first day that he was in the
Gulf War
um that he had hit in a rocky tank
from 500 yards away and also another
story that he likes to tell and I'm
guessing this is true
but that like with his uh Cannon he
actually like shot off a dude's head
like what like an Iraqi like popped up
like that and he like shot his head off
like it went off like in a Red Mist or
something and apparently that was like
kind of um
a formative moment I guess it seemed
like because he brought it up more than
once
so um he actually over the course of the
war got several Service Awards he got
the Bronze Star
uh metal like National Defense service
medal Southwest Asia service medal Army
Service ribbon and the Kuwait Liberation
medal so he got a bunch of stuff there
now he actually wanted to join
Special Forces
so after he got back from his tour of
the gulf in the Gulf War he actually
went into the selection program for
Special Forces
but on the second day of the three-week
thing he
um dropped out yeah now he told the
other guys that it was because oh I hurt
myself like I hurt my ankle
but uh they had the letter to his
superiors where he said that he was not
quote unquote physically ready yeah so
that could be the same thing right yeah
I don't know if that's what it meant or
not
so he actually decided after that the
thing is the selection is in three weeks
this was been a pre-selection maybe
maybe yeah it's just that I'm just
reading from my notes and it just said a
selection program for Army Special
Forces and it was a 21-day assess
assessment
is what it was and selection course so I
guess they were seeing like who had the
could go on to like the main thing maybe
yeah because the Q the Q course which is
what we would consider selection that
goes on I think that's several months
you know from what I remember
okay so I don't think it was selection I
think it might have been a pre-selection
well like I said it says assessment okay
assessment yeah okay
all right yeah so I'm just saying that
it's probably like the pre like the
pre-code it's three weeks yeah so he was
in there for two days kind of like
pre-rip he had Ranger school but he had
to go through uh [ __ ] pre-raanger
which is if you can make if you can make
it through this [ __ ] little two-week
course you got a good chance of making
it through Raider School
G4 Mafia said elite units are Elite for
a reason exactly yeah yeah very very few
people their whole job is to eliminate
you and I did not make it through Ranger
school okay I didn't make it to Ranger
school [ __ ] um well you said it was
the the swimming one or the water swim
test kind of stuff yeah I had to go down
and go get a [ __ ] rucksack off the
bottom of the [ __ ] pool I think it
was 12 foot pool and swim back up when
you're in full equipment with helmet and
rifle and on the way up I [ __ ]
dropped that thing and so I went in
there to swim back down to go get it and
they pulled me up I was on the line
never says and I said do you pull me up
because it could have got it you're on a
time limit and it says Oh no you're
running out of time you never would have
you would have made it you wouldn't have
made it anyway and you there was like
three things that you could fit uh if
you failed three things that was it and
I don't remember what the other two
things were but I was pissed off over
that swim test
wait a minute I might be getting
confused with aib
expert infantry bed it was just I don't
think you could fail anything out of
[ __ ] pre-ranger
you had to be able to make everything
remember
so it was swim test yeah
it's hard you're in boots with a helmet
yeah you know all that drag on you and
then the [ __ ] rucksack fills up the
[ __ ] water it's on a line
but they're not going to pull up the
line you have to [ __ ] swing you have
to swim up with it and the [ __ ] right
you have to have a rifle slung across
your back M16 A2
I imagine that knocks out a lot of
people
yeah a lot of people get knocked out by
[ __ ] like that swim test
I could see that because that's like
really really difficult even for people
that are like in really good shape yeah
uh it not in those days it was knocking
a lot of black guys out they're weak
swimmers
um they don't grow up in an environment
where swim from little kids and we were
always trying to figure it out
black dudes in the Infantry tended to
sink and they're very I think it was
because they got a high bone density
and they were lean they tend to be very
lean so there was no flotation on them
yeah yeah right you know a guy who's
made it through the black guy who's made
it through the Infantry he's usually
lame at least in the time I was in so
they're not real good at floating so it
requires more effort and they're in
Boots
with a helmet so they were at a slight
handicap I think it's just because of
leanness
and Bone Dance probably yeah it probably
has something to do Race Matters when it
comes to the Wild and physical [ __ ]
you know
white white people can [ __ ]
tolerate cold a lot more than non-whites
and we die later you'll start to see
black guys
start suffering from [ __ ]
um
yeah I mean like everything else it's a
spectrum but there it is you start
seeing them first they're like the
canaries in the coal mine we're going
it's getting cold those guys are going
down if they go down we're only 20
minutes behind them the difference is
only minutes yeah but
the black guys go down first from cold
weather injury
yeah just the way it is biology [ __ ]
you can't run from it
but like you said it's not a huge huge
difference
it was enough to make a difference a
long time ago before everybody had
modern clothing
yeah but still you put dudes in [ __ ]
20 degrees below zero the clothing
aren't as [ __ ] critical as you think
they are it's hard to [ __ ] survive
that amount of wind chill you know
man I was watching a [ __ ] one of
those shows the other day that like I
survived whatever yeah like an old one
and that and remember that guy like that
guy that guy survived like in a car yeah
for like two weeks yeah in like Sub-Zero
temperatures and all he had was like a
sleeping bag and like some [ __ ] rice
cakes yeah I was like man that guy's got
some will to live well he survived
because of that sleeping bag he never
would have made it without us well no he
would have Frozen today well because
yeah he wasn't planning on like getting
stuck out there in the [ __ ] middle of
it he was just driving somewhere and the
car broke down you know what I mean and
then like there was a blizzard and he
got buried but yeah he was out there for
two [ __ ] weeks eating like [ __ ]
all he had was rice rice cakes and
banana chips yeah and a sleeping bag and
just like regular ass clothes like he
didn't have a coat or nothing I don't
think or nothing like you know
so you know I mean it can be done but
yeah
I kind of feel like most of the time
it's not gonna happen
but yeah so uh so he got honorably
discharged like he decided to leave the
Army after he called to be an
anthropologist now yeah Anthropologist
now yeah
uh Linex Warriors said it's nothing to
do with high bone density American
blacks are usually Urban in the uh
Caribbean and Africa black Deeds be
swimming all the time yeah yeah I think
it's more like a cultural like how they
grow up more yeah but the guys that the
guys that were going the black guys that
were going through pre-range or in
Ranger school were from the south and
right and could swim it's just that they
didn't quite swim as well as us and and
it's and they seemed it seemed to be to
do that particular test
because they were leaner they had to put
out more energy to get it up off the
[ __ ] bottom of the [ __ ] pool and
swim up the top with it and we noticed
that guys that had a little bit more fat
on them
floated better so that particular task
well that's easier it was easier to do
because the guys that were getting
knocked out the black guys were getting
knocked out were all lead lean [ __ ]
high muscle density good bone density on
them great Runner bodies you know what I
mean they're like good runner type guys
which [ __ ] a ranger gotta run too
infantry got to run it's that's a good
skill
but they were lean so that particular
test it was harder for them
Camp guy says women have an actual extra
layer of fat over their bodies that men
do not have actual anatomical difference
in the Sexes
um and he said uh where did it go makes
women stronger than men in some survival
situations I taught lifeguard training
yeah
um I think it is generally easier for
like women to float because they just
generally are fat more fat content you
know that's just biology it doesn't so
there you go you got a lifeguard degree
of women
yeah
infantry black dudes tended to be lean
which that gave him a lot of advantages
but not on that damn swim test
okay
it was better to be a little bit fat
for that test that particular probably
not for the running or for some other
things but see that's the thing it's
like nobody is good at everything like
everybody's gonna have some so that's
kind of like where they get you yeah so
that's kind of why you know so many
people get knocked out of it because
it's very very rare for somebody to be
good at like all of those things right
you know what I mean like equally
laughs
oh man uh Jones Perkins says uh you guys
are so entertaining I can't figure out
why you're not more popular they're not
as [ __ ] Shadow bed man I don't think
we take over [ __ ] we would take over
you too we're almost we're almost at 13
000. I'm excited [ __ ] man they got
[ __ ] channels that'll make [ __ ] 20
000 [ __ ] twenty thousand well I know
subscribers a week
get up to like 1.5 million I know that
and then they have to say we got to shut
them off their 2 million they'll do that
too to people but uh I don't know why
just it's how it is like share subscribe
we're an acquired taste like share
subscribers it's a good talk show
uh we're about halfway through this well
okay look okay once you get to don't
forget we got commercials we gotta play
well I know that okay it's like we're
not even halfway through yet just calm
down I mean some of the stuff I'm gonna
Skip it's like I have more I always have
more notes than like I actually use
because some of the stuff like I I kind
of like read this stuff through earlier
and like watch documentaries but then
like when I'm reading it I'm like yeah
it's kind of boring I'm gonna skip that
but whatever Zach says uh ironically the
most toxic Community I've been in
outside of some anime fandoms like
online is the screenwriting subreddit
yeah
um
I believe it I believe it yeah you'd
think that it's like [ __ ] that is about
stuff that's like not even that
important like in the green screen
scheme of things like people get really
really
um they get really into it and I I don't
understand I don't understand like why
people get so upset about stuff that
doesn't really matter
like in the grand scheme of things I
don't know I don't get it I don't get it
gotta slide down there slide he's a
black veteran from the Army
and he's given his statistics he's five
eight he weighs 170 pounds he weighed
that for 25 years until he reached 50
and now he weighs 185.
he's five eight so um
I'm still 10 pounds heavier than you now
you got we gotta look at the damn
we got to look at the uh uh what do you
call it uh the body composition how much
muscle how much fat that's a factor
but Sly you were there you remember
those second Infantry
dudes
um going through [ __ ] pre-aranger
schools especially the black guys tended
to be the better Runners and they also
tended to be lean they had more problem
with swim tests the white dudes are like
kind of I don't know they're almost like
Eskimos some of them had a little bit
more fat on them but they can still
complete Those runs in the courses they
just floated better
and the black dudes that were going
through the ranger programs when I was
in they were all country dudes they were
from the south so they grew up swimming
you know they weren't they weren't Urban
like the other guy said they were
Southern
Texas Mississippi Alabama Louisiana out
the middle of nowhere
same profile
same culture as the white guys
uh Ben says we're doing commercials now
sponsorship shekels no we're not uh
we're not sponsored by anybody there are
commercials for like uh my stuff that I
that I make like books and games and
stuff uh Camp guy said women's extra
layer of body fat is probably related to
the evolution of childbearing needs yeah
I think that's exactly what it is
because honestly
um you know from a child bearing point
of view obviously it's more important
for the woman to live longer so she
needs more fat stores she needs more
stuff so like she can feed babies and
stuff like that so that's why
um yeah Ben says very crazy people get
obsessed with movie characters and
actors all the time that's probably what
it is
um it's just very silly to me that
you know I know why it happens but it is
very silly to me that like so many
people get so
emotionally invested in
movie character like stuff that isn't
real like I love that [ __ ] too like I
geek out about horror movies I geek at a
ball and stuff but like I'm not gonna be
one of those people that's like you know
if a movie comes out in a franchise that
I loved and it's like and I don't like
it I'm not gonna get like oh my God it's
the worst thing ever it's like I'm not
gonna get like that because it's like
geez calm down there's more poor things
to worry about I got bigger problems you
know what I mean I got way bigger
problems than like that kind of crap but
yeah
but you know I I can see how people that
maybe
don't have other problems or maybe like
dissociating their actual problems onto
like fictional problems maybe that's
what it is I don't know I'm not a
psychologist so I don't really know
so uh so yeah so McVeigh gets out of the
Army in 1991 he was honorably discharged
because like I said he didn't uh make it
through to Special Forces
so at this point he started
um writing letters to the newspapers you
know complaining about stuff
this was in 1992 and they still have
like a lot of his stuff obviously
because it was all published so um you
know complaining about your kind of
standard sort of stuff uh that people
would be complaining about about uh
taxes
um talking about imminent Civil War so
you're talking about that back in 1992
um now one thing that he did write
complaining about he actually wrote to
um one of his Representatives at the
time
whose name was uh John lafalse and he
actually wrote him a letter complaining
about a woman who I don't know if she
got arrested or she got in trouble or
something like that for like carrying
mace in her purse which you know I I
don't I don't like to be agreeing with
Timothy McVeigh on anything but it's
like yeah I'm kind of with him on that
like I don't really like think that you
should get in trouble for like hearing
Mason your purse for Christ's sake I
mean it's not like it's gonna kill
anybody you know you know and it's like
a good like kind of self-defense thing
so uh so yeah
so he kind of goes through this where
he's like writing letters to newspapers
all the time
now later like I said he's kind of like
a little bit of a Drifter it felt like
he didn't really have you know he didn't
really have any ambition in Life or
anything like that so he's just kind of
like wandering from place to place and
he moved in with Terry Nichols
um and they lived on Terry Nichols had a
brother named James
and they he had a farm
uh in Michigan
so he moved in there so they were all
kind of like living there together
now apparently around this time period
Timothy McVeigh started complaining that
the Army had put a microchip in his butt
that was tracking him like the Army had
put it in there
so hold on wait I was stepped away he
thought he got injected by microchip
there was a microchip in his butt
Timothy even faded I didn't realize he
said that yeah that like that yeah well
obviously
I don't think they had that technology
that kind of Technology now that kind of
sound yeah but that I mean that was the
kind of [ __ ] that people were saying
like back in the early 90s like oh my
God they planted like a microchip it's
like you know that's kind of like [ __ ]
that not not to be me that's like [ __ ]
that schizophrenic say like that think
that people are like implanting stuff
and like tracking you it's like [ __ ]
nobody cares what you're doing just
trust me nobody cares but yeah he
thought that somebody had implanted a
microchip in his butt
so they could track him
um so yeah so we had a job but it wasn't
like a great one you know what I mean
um and he's just kind of living in with
his friends and their family or whatever
uh and I guess he kind of developed a
crush on are you drinking my drink now
okay I thought you were you were just
like not looking at you were just like
taking it and I was like what are you
doing
so um and he I guess he kind of like
developed a crush on a co-worker
but um you know and maybe like asked her
out and she was like not rather not and
then he got like real uh kind of upset
about that and so he wasn't real like I
said he had a little bit of an in-cell
Vibe going on too like he wasn't real um
he wasn't real slick with women
so there's that too
so that probably wasn't helping because
I kind of feel like he felt like he was
like
um like I said just a drift in life he
didn't really have any ambition like
bigger Ambitions he couldn't really find
a girlfriend and he was frustrated about
that
um you know so and he was mad about
taxes and about the thing in his butt
and all this other kind of stuff
so
um he starts getting like uh a gambling
problem too
and then he spent so much money gambling
that he went into like horrible debt and
then got a loan to try to pay back the
debt but then he couldn't pay back the
loan you know what I mean so there was
that
um and then uh it adding salt like
throwing salt on the wound I guess he
got a letter evidently that um that he
had been overpaid by the Army like while
he was in the Army by like if they
wanted by like a thousand dollars or
something and like they wanted it back
oh and he got like really really bad
about that like he like he wrote them a
letter and everything part of the letter
said go ahead take everything I own take
my dignity feel good as you grow fat and
Rich at my expense sucking my tax
dollars and property which like I said I
feel that okay I feel the frustration
but it's just kind of like
I don't know man I guess
you're gonna get [ __ ] over that's just
what life is like you know what I mean
no matter where you were
um so
at this point like Timothy McVeigh is
just very very you know anti-federal
government anti-everything he got his
sister all into it like his dad was just
kind of like yeah whatever he didn't
want to hear it but like he got his
sister kind of into it too
so his dad was kind of like yeah you
might want to like move out and so he
moved out into like some kind of like
shitty little apartment now the
apartment apparently didn't have a
telephone because I'm assuming he
couldn't afford one so he had a job but
like his you know the his manager or
whatever would like try to call him like
hey can you come in or something like
that and he didn't have a phone so
there's that now he was a member at the
NRA of this time but he quit around this
time period because he thought that they
were too weak on gun rights so there was
that
so um 1993 the Waco Siege Siege takes
place
and uh McVeigh was so incensed by this
that he actually drove there like while
it was going on because it went on for
quite a long time
and he went there to kind of like join
the protest or like show his support you
know for the for the Branch Davidians
and while he was there and there's like
film of him there too like sitting on
the front of like the hood of his car or
whatever
and so he starts like passing out
literature and bumper stickers and stuff
like that
uh at the at the Waco thing
so uh after the Waco Siege took place
he started going around like I said he
would go around the country to like gun
shows and stuff like that and he started
handing out
um
cards with the name and address of uh
Lon horiuchi who is the guy at Ruby
Ridge who had shot the the woman and the
baby
she's trying to dox him so he well he
did he's doxing him yeah he did and he's
basically like he didn't come out I mean
I was gonna say he didn't come out and
say it but he did come out and say
um he would put the on the card it said
in the hope that somebody in the Patriot
movement would assassinate the
Sharpshooter so he was like handing
those out at gun shows and stuff like
that so he was he was an FBI sniper that
guy like John horiachi yeah he pulled
the trigger and when he shouldn't have
right right but the way [ __ ] big vase
handling this that's what I mean I'm not
saying that like what he did was what
horiuchi did was good obviously it
wasn't but I'm just saying that it's
like that's not cool either that doesn't
that doesn't make it better yeah two
wrongs don't make a right exactly that's
you know that's a lesson that should
have been imparted like like much
earlier than this it's just you know
could have used that dude as a tool to
dismantle the ATF if you're pissed at
the ATF you know you just the [ __ ]
brutal way of hey knock this
[ __ ] off nah that'll never work
out and the thing about it is like even
even if you had done that right like you
know just obviously that's morally
repugnant like I said but it's like what
would that accomplish and accomplish
anything I don't think it would
accomplish anything they'd hire four
more Shooters like that even from a
pragmatic standpoint it's not
they're fighting you're fighting an
institution and that's not how you
that's not how you fight institutions
you fight institutions with lawyers in
public sentiment that's how you do it
foreign
yeah so there was that
now
um
the thing about it was that when Timothy
McVeigh was first thinking about his
plan like to get back at the U.S
government for Waco and Ruby Ridge which
was kind of his main thing
um like you said he was initially gonna
do a campaign of assassination and
horayuchi was actually high up on his
list of like people that he wanted to
assassinate
um so he actually was gonna do that like
before
the whole uh bombing situation
so he becomes
um kind of like a little bit well known
like on the gun show circuit like I said
he'd go around the country and he would
like kind of um he went like almost all
over the U.S honestly like to different
gun shows and he would start
um he'd sold stuff like he would sell
like um like someone mentioned earlier
he'd sell copies of the Turner Diaries
which you know if you don't know that
came out in 1978 and was written by a
Neo-Nazi like under a pseudonym and it's
basically like
it's a fictional novel but like I said
it's kind of like a polemic in the sense
that it's
kind of like a training manual well yeah
it's it's basically like white it's a
white supremacist Bible is what it is
because they're like we basically want
to kill all blacks Jews liberals that
kind of stuff like that's what the story
is about and the opening scene of the
book is
um somebody blowing up a federal
building with a truck bomb so they think
that that's probably where he got the
idea to do that I was like oh that
sounds like a good idea you know what I
mean from the Turner tires because he
loved that [ __ ] book and he even had
like notes from it like and I think even
when they pulled him over like when they
caught him like for the bombing like he
had like copied pages of it like in his
car like in a folder and stuff like that
he was really really into that but I've
never read it so I really can't comment
on it it was my understanding that the
the importance of the book really didn't
have anything to do with
the topics of [ __ ] like white
supremacy or anything what it was it was
more like a training manual on how to
how to start it Uprising or a rebellion
and the tactics that were used it's
absolutely about white supremacy
yeah but that's not why they were
reading it
based on [ __ ] what I remember
like I said I never read it it was
mostly talking about
what the tactics to use
to start an uprising and to bring down a
government that that's why they were
reading it it didn't really didn't have
anything to do anything else it was just
like more like a training manual
well I mean yeah our characters were
that way you can say that but like a
couple of white supremacist groups used
it as justification for
um some other similarly Terror attacks
evidently like I said evidently this is
like a really poorly written book and
whatever doesn't surprise yeah it's just
not really I've heard people that read
it the synopsis is this it's not really
a good read and it's poorly written it
was more of a a way of of demonstrating
certain tactics that you could use
against law enforcement and a federal
government
to uh how to attack things like power uh
power distribution centers You Know
Places they're attacking the the
infrastructure of a state or a
government to get it to collapse and to
get the to get the population to rise up
in a in a revolt and that they would
kill each other too during the rebellion
was that's that's part of it so that's
the reason why I mean that was what I
was told the reason why they were
reading it mostly more like a training
manual than anything else
didn't have a lot to do with ideology
because they already had that ideology
yeah they didn't need to spread that
ideology they already had it it was the
training Factor by in the story
evidently why they were reading it
it was you know
which I guess McVeigh did that but the
thing is is that those tactics tend not
to work
so I don't know why they're worried
about it it's pretty old-fashioned
they just they just don't work you start
attacking a government openly like that
they retaliate okay
and uh
it doesn't really
they tend to button up and become even
more hardcore
uh if you really want to [ __ ] destroy
a government best thing to do is just
ridicule it and expose it expose the
crimes that it's doing
and then
um
get like-minded people to go to work for
that government and once they get inside
there you start usurping it and and
um and then you can you basically want a
situation like what you saw with the
Soviet Union where one day it's there
three days later it no longer exists
everybody just walked away from it
because its money wasn't worth anything
nobody wanted to work for it nobody
believed in it
that's how you really do it
if you [ __ ] start attacking a
government with Kinetic force in other
words fighting it you now justify that
government's existence so that so it's
counter
you know I mean it counters what what
the goal is
you want that government to become
overbearing
you want it to become stupid
and you want it to become tyrannical
that way it will lose public support
so in some ways maybe attacking it you
might be able to get it to crack down
that way so it becomes you're trying to
you're trying to make the government
become a totalitarian Society because
nobody will like that
you can get rid of it that way but
that's
kind of an inefficient way of doing it
what you want is you want what happened
in the Soviet Union just undermine
undermine undermine
20 years of that and a bunch of
parastrika strikes the next in labor
strikes and tax strikes and the next
thing you know people just walk away
from it
all right so I'm gonna run some
commercials because I have to go to the
bathroom
so if
see I'm I'm gonna do commercial string
two first okay
if that if I'm not back I'll go back to
one then go
and now it's acknowledged president
[Music]
you died
[Music]
with the life
of the last of the game
Flames expired
darkness and decay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
we're back
we've both gone to the restroom what's
that what's the matter I was looking for
my glasses where'd they go how would I
know I must have set them down
where are my glasses he never knows
where his glasses
are uh okay so where was I
okay so it got to a point where
Timothy McVeigh was one of those guys
that it's like he had a map that had all
of the what he thought were the most
likely targets for nuclear attacks like
on the map and he's like I'm gonna buy
some property like away from that like
in a kind of you know in a Zone where
they're not gonna like bomb so he moves
in with the third guy uh Michael Fortier
they moved to Arizona
now the two of them actually like lived
together for a time now 40a was real
into
myth let's let's say that who was who
isn't it
Michael Fortier the third he was the
third guy that they that they knew yeah
uh kind of a but I don't know if I'd go
so far as say co-conspirator but kind of
so uh yeah so yeah they were smoking pot
but you know I don't give a [ __ ] about
that but yeah so they were both doing
myth
now apparently like Timothy McVeigh did
it too but I guess he wasn't as into it
as like um the other dude was because I
think one of the reasons that they
stopped like
you know that he moved out was because
Michael 48 was like a meth head you know
what I mean
so uh so basically April of 1993. uh
Timothy McVeigh goes back to the farm in
Michigan where Terry Nichols lived after
living in Arizona with the other with
the meth head
so uh because of the Waco Siege this
seemed like it was kind of like the the
final nail in the coffin where Timothy
McVeigh was like well I have to do
something and apparently Terry Nichols
was kind of of the same mind because
they start
basically like making explosive like
pipe bombs and [ __ ] like that uh in
their houses you know making explosives
in jugs and crap like that
so
um and then like at the gun shows that
he was still going to he starts doing
[ __ ] like
um you know selling uh ATF hats that had
like bullet holes shot through them
um you know flare guns that he said
could shoot down an ATF helicopter [ __ ]
like that yeah I'd like to see that yeah
that's what I was thinking I was like
that must be some flare gun yeah I could
see that yeah a flare gun that can shoot
down a helicopter I don't think he knows
what a flare is motherfucker's lying
that's some [ __ ] right there just
didn't have the mass it just bounced off
a damn helicopter come on
yeah he's telling that to the Rubes well
yeah he was just trying to sell some
[ __ ] probably yeah
but yeah he had all like all these kind
of pamphlets and [ __ ] like that that he
was like giving out and selling and crap
like that so um
also in the house him and Terry Nichols
or like I said making pipe bombs
experimenting with various explosives uh
and [ __ ] like that
so there was all of that kind of
nonsense going on
so uh there was another thing that he
was rolling to too because remember how
I said like after the Waco while the
Waco thing was going on
like if there were protesters and stuff
and he actually went there he kind of
like for some reason felt the need to
like go places like where he thought I
don't know what he thought he was going
to do exactly but he actually went they
know that he actually went to Area 51
because he thought there was like some
[ __ ] going on there aliens man yeah I
guess or like anywhere that he thought
that the government was covering
something up he's like I'm gonna go
check this out for myself kind of
situation like I said I don't know what
he thought he was gonna do when he got
there but you can't get in there well
yeah that's what I'm saying it's like
what did you think you were gonna do
you're just gonna sit there in your car
and like no one's No One's Gonna Be
intimidated
private security they won't let you into
the [ __ ] rank it's a range that's all
it's a [ __ ] aircraft range you ain't
getting in there
yeah I mean you know it's yeah that's
just McDonald Douglas [ __ ] Lockheed
Lockheed Martin
I don't know I kind of feel they're
these kind of guys I kind of feel like
there's a little bit of
I think they think that they're like
more important or scary than they
actually are in real life
he thought something was being hidden
from him
right from him specifically yeah and I'm
just kind of like expose it yeah and I'm
just like no you're not gonna I admire
his balls though
I'm gonna figure this [ __ ] out I'm gonna
show y'all they're lying they got a UFO
I saw alien autopsy
we're gonna see it I'm not laughing at
UFOs or anything when did it when did
aliens when did alien autopsy come out
that must have been around 96. maybe 95
96 I remember when it came out I read it
I rented it from the local [ __ ] you
actually yeah I wanted to see that [ __ ]
I was [ __ ] amazed man I was I had to
watch stop [ __ ] laughing I had to
watch that thing three or four times and
really like
it was a different era okay it was a
very different time I had to watch that
[ __ ] video three or four times
and to get over the the initial emotions
behind it to where I could just
rationally analyze what I was being seen
and I went
no no that's that's a reenactment can't
be
you know that's a rubber dummy but it
took me a couple times I had to they've
only been doing an autopsy right it's
like have you guys ever seen a [ __ ]
right NCIS or anything like that come on
that's pretty low Tech man for [ __ ]
doing an autopsy on an alien body and
they're just pulling [ __ ] out of there
that that's that's just random you're
just pulling out stuff they're not
measuring it or like putting it they
weren't doing anything like that that
you would normally do if this is like an
alien yeah and they're just doing it in
like a fake doctor's office that could
have been anywhere you know it looked
like just an empty room with a clock I
remember that and some tables and I'm
like wait a minute even in the 40s they
would have been a group of dudes like
seven or eight
[ __ ] doctors and they would have been
this [ __ ] would have went slowly what
they're doing well yeah like I said this
is an alien right right they'd have been
like super careful there have been like
all kind of people in there like looking
at it it wouldn't have been a general
[ __ ] thing like meatball surgery
where we just had somebody open and
throw some [ __ ] in a bag
it wouldn't have been one film it would
have been about a hundred of them each
one of them about five and it would have
been did slowly meticulously detailing
yeah skin texture because the anatomy
would have been entirely different they
would have been like cataloging every
single day yeah they would have had a
whole [ __ ] hour-long future of making
an incision along the abdomen and
[ __ ] you know and they would have
been all kinds of stuff
because that's the way those dudes did
[ __ ] back then yeah it just didn't
they're a lot more advanced than you
think they were in the 40s 30s 50s
this [ __ ] wore pocket
protectors okay they wore pocket
protectors they had glasses they had
slide rules they thought about [ __ ] they
talked about it they wrote it down on
napkins while they were drinking [ __ ]
they'd have to have titty girls out of
the [ __ ] bar and they're talking
about rocket technology okay [ __ ] my
granddad was one of them all right they
took that [ __ ] very seriously they
thought about it because they didn't
have computers you couldn't rely on a
computer
so everything was done by a plan by a
team [ __ ] wore ties they had a
tie on when they did this okay short
sleeve shirts pocket protector tie and
[ __ ] coke bottle glasses like nerdy
as [ __ ]
that's who would have been there
good about 20 of them nerds made the
world big nerding the [ __ ] out yeah and
it would everything would have been done
real slowly we left it up to y'all dumb
[ __ ] we'd still be like living
in caves and that body they wouldn't
have had that body just sitting on a
table all right it would be sitting in a
[ __ ] like a an aquarium filled with
[ __ ] ice
and oh you'd have only seen where they
were making that incision because they
would want to mess with that body for
[ __ ] months
so it would never be off of ice
I think it would be constantly kept real
cold they wouldn't want it to rot
you know they just had this [ __ ] sitting
up on the table because it was just made
of rubber this is made of rubber yeah so
that's why yeah they actually even
figured out where they got it from like
later on they were able to like Source
where they got it from you I had to calm
down though that's why I said Tom rented
alien autopsy
that's what I said [ __ ] off get the [ __ ]
off a channel ban that man no I [ __ ]
dude it was the times man [ __ ] that
[ __ ] came out the video store I was
living in Boston at that time and I
rented that [ __ ] and the [ __ ] people
bostonians are [ __ ] some snooty
[ __ ] I ran into rent that [ __ ]
and they were [ __ ] snickering looking
at each other I would have snickered
dude you're not gonna lie
it's real aliens shut up because I kept
going in there getting alien [ __ ] I lost
all respect from these [ __ ] people
that worked at the damn videos
Yankees you know how'd that make you
feel Tom made me feel bad [ __ ] is
Yankees that's how they do [ __ ] man
they're looking at me rolling there like
I said I'm from the south and I probably
would have laughed at you yeah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] I want to see the [ __ ]
alien
he's watching X-Files and [ __ ] well
there's nothing wrong with The X-Files
that's fictional I was watching that too
man that's why that alien autopsy video
appeared because of X-Files because that
was big well yeah that was like that was
a cultural phenomena and then they came
out with that people everybody [ __ ]
looked at it
Rickshaw said I I miss video stores yeah
I do too a little bit a little bit I
mean it's much better nowadays because I
can just watch whatever the [ __ ] I want
like whenever the [ __ ] I want which is
like
that's where you can you can meet a cute
girl at the video store you had cute
ones working in there you had cute ones
going in there renting videos you trying
to chase them it'd be it was good back
in the day you know you're you're in
your way you chased him around around
the thing like like on the Benny Hill
show yeah you're like how you doing what
kind of a UFC because there was no
internet you know and I was in my 20s
back then
so you know you could do that back then
I'd be like I'm writing Cannibal
Holocaust yeah you're like oh yeah yeah
yeah when you were like [ __ ] 22 you
were looking for one it was like 18 or
19. so you're younger than you you know
[ __ ] because you know you might be
able to impress her because you wouldn't
impress a nobody at 24. you didn't have
a [ __ ] money
you know
but it eights here and a 19 year old
girl she's just out of the house maybe
she might for all you know she's a high
school senior or something you know yeah
yeah I was hanging out yeah she's still
like dumb and naive you're a big move up
you're a big step up you can buy you can
buy you can you can get booze and [ __ ]
yeah I remember yeah get us some booze
and stuff go get us some boobs we'll be
over at your place yeah they're like
four of them to show up hey yeah all of
them under age girls are practical yeah
yeah
do you like 22 you're thinking you're
King of the [ __ ] world man
they just like that you're over 21 and
you can buy them yeah you're over 21
yeah
it's just that's how it was but it was
they don't really like you for you they
just like your ability to buy beer it
didn't matter it didn't matter in those
days it didn't matter I know men dudes
were practical too you're like okay
Rickshaw said I miss chasing women
around me and stuff yeah they weren't
women they were girls
I wasn't quite a man 22 23 24 running
out
they're like 19 20. a couple years
younger you know all right so where was
I we got distracted by Area 51 yeah area
55 [ __ ] one because I didn't know he
was 51. yeah he actually went to area so
he's full spectrum he's full spectrum
he's trying to find aliens full spectrum
of something full spectrum yeah he's
aliens pipe bombs uh worried about the
ATF [ __ ] yeah okay he's got the whole
[ __ ] conspiracy package going on like
all the all the conspiracy if you got a
conspiracy he's gonna he's gonna buy
into that [ __ ] yeah but yeah yeah and
they're ex-militaries so they do have
some skills and some some experience so
it's uh it's strange but you know
uh you know [ __ ] I've seen I've seen
the interviews with him
his his uh his understanding of [ __ ]
how to deal with [ __ ] America's
problems weren't [ __ ] uh weren't
really [ __ ] wasn't the most efficient
he's not as sophisticated no simple well
the thing about it is that he like I
said um I don't know if you were here
when I said but he had like an above
average yeah IQ like he wasn't a dummy
they used Dan Foe and they made a bunch
of [ __ ] right they they had technical
expertise really and intelligence but
naivete though very naive
yeah I I just kind of feel like in a lot
of ways it's like they were good at
things like they could do things but
they didn't roll they didn't have a real
sophisticated grasp on on [ __ ]
politics yeah [ __ ] and how Society
works and how they're we're gonna react
to this they thought they were gonna
make they thought this ship was gonna
catch on
okay he really did he really did seem to
think that they were going to be [ __ ]
like revolutionary [ __ ] the founders
of a revolution there'll be heroes later
on in history no that's not how this
shit's gonna work your your movement has
to win before history can be Rewritten
and when you don't win you're always
written out as the villain okay
uh other guys like this we're written in
as Heroes all America's Revolutionary
[ __ ] Heroes where guys kind of like
this they were breaking into judges
houses and tar and Feathering them [ __ ]
like that nowadays they call that a
terrorist you know [ __ ] George
Washington would have been a terrorist
by today's standards by the standards I
think the British just considered him a
[ __ ] terrorist you know so you have
to win all right and there's no way
these guys are going to win he should
have thought they should have known that
but optimism I guess
is expending energy on on a tactic
that's not gonna work
high profile explosions and [ __ ] on
federal buildings
you're not going to [ __ ] win hearts
and Minds by doing that it's not going
to become a thing
it's just not well [ __ ] it honestly it
really it spectacularly backfired
because not only did everybody like
immediately think he was a monster and
hate him but they even actually talked
about like people so many people wanted
to see him get executed that they had to
have a [ __ ] Lottery right because
they couldn't fit all the people that
wanted to see him die yep that's how
much they [ __ ] hated him he didn't
control the media and no there's no
propaganda Outlets so [ __ ] they can
spin a narrative they can say whatever
they want about you and you can't
counter it so they can turn public
against you
and an average person during that time
had no idea what this was I remember I
was there at the time the average person
had no idea what happened he just some
dude that blew up a building killed some
kids they're no you know I mean the
public isn't all that bright either well
but the thing about it I didn't know why
I did it is that well yeah but what I'm
going to say is that yeah maybe he had a
reason and maybe he even had a
legitimate reason but like blowing up a
bunch of innocent babies and a bunch of
innocent people is not you're that's not
going to endear anyone or like bring
anyone over to your cause I don't think
he had a legitimate reason for blowing
that building no he didn't I'm just
saying even if you did he had a
legitimate reason to be to be to be mad
but sure but but the response wasn't
correct but a lot of people have
legitimate reasons for being mad about a
lot of things but that doesn't mean that
you can do [ __ ] like this right you have
to [ __ ] understand
the tides of society [ __ ] American
society wasn't what was pretty much
happy during this period they weren't
going to turn against the government
they just weren't okay yeah I mean
nothing was really I mean yeah a lot of
people were mad about Waco a lot of
people were mad about Ruby Ridge and not
just like because you know my [ __ ]
liberal ass I was I was mad about that
[ __ ] too because that was [ __ ] up a
lot of people were mad about that but
it's like that doesn't give you the
right to go blow up a bunch of [ __ ]
innocent people and you're not gonna get
and if you think that that's that that
you're going to get people to turn
against the government because you did
or Inspire them it's not going to happen
no because this [ __ ] like this had
happened already at a smaller scale
going out to the beginning of time in
American history and it didn't happen
before
there was [ __ ] that happened in the 20s
and the 30s the [ __ ] was pretty
hardcore but you don't even it's all
forgotten because it really didn't
amount to anything I still wanted to do
a show about the Wall Street bombing
that happened in the 19th there were
some Puerto Ricans that ran into the
Capitol building and shot up a bunch of
people and that's forgotten
they were yeah I mean [ __ ] like that
just happens like all that yeah it
happens like all the time yeah and it's
happening yeah so if people forget about
it Presidents assassinated people forget
about it just you know so blowing up
that building wasn't going to change
anything
you have to change society and you can
only do that through culture and that
takes a long time
and
the American people would have had to
have reached a conclusion on their own
because of the [ __ ] over because of
the environment that it was time to
have a revolutionary change in the
government you know what I mean or in
this system that it's not something you
can force into being by doing some kind
of an attack it's not how it's never
worked that way
even in other countries that never
worked that way
no so I
I don't know why they bothered it
doesn't make any sense to me
well he was just mad and he just he had
anger and he needed a place he needed an
outlet to put it and he picked like the
worst possible thing the thing is it
took him a long time to prepare for this
you would think that the Egger would
have subsided they thought that [ __ ] was
going to work it wasn't just emotion
they thought it was going to work that
there was going to be a massive Uprising
yeah but they did think that they did
they thought that but it no I don't know
why they would think that I don't know
either there was no evidence to suggest
that all the s all the evidence if you
look throughout American history
suggested the opposite
that the public would support the
government not go against it it's just
the thinking was crazy
yeah like I said I don't really know
what they thought they were going to
accomplish yeah but it didn't happen
yeah this kind of attack doesn't work no
so uh so yeah
we talked about like I said Area 51
that's where we got distracted all right
so
um Timothy McVeigh and Terry Nichols
start making a whole bunch of uh
purchases in bulk of ammonium nitrate
which is fertilizer in case you didn't
know
um and they were gonna start reselling
it to other survivalist type of dudes
um they thought that the government was
going to ban it which didn't happen but
I guess like rumors were swirling around
in those circles so they thought we're
gonna buy it all up and yeah they were
threatened the government was
threatening to ban Imodium nitrate right
and to put tags in it which is like
these little microscopic [ __ ]
pieces of silicate that had serial
numbers written on it I remember when
they were talking about that they could
track all that yeah I remember that yeah
they never they never really do that
though
it was all propaganda
they couldn't do that Ben said wasn't it
meant to be a signal as per the Turner
Diaries yeah that other extremists would
start bombing as well yeah they thought
well like I said if you read like the
first part of like the Turner Diaries
um it's essentially what he was using
for an idea you know what I mean it's
like this this is kind of gonna set off
like this man he's tripping the Turner
Diaries wasn't written by some kind of a
[ __ ] military genius or anything
that's not how revolutions happen but
like I said this is a guy who's he's not
dumb but he's kind of just gone down
this one particular
single Rail and it's like he's very
single-minded and he surrounded himself
with other people who thought like that
too he didn't really have anybody saying
being like bro that's a really stupid
idea I don't think he did it just seemed
like everybody else that was around was
agreed with him he thought he thought I
guess he thought the country would just
ripe for an uprising
but yeah he was saying that back in 1992
yeah but it wasn't I mean it wasn't
I was around during that time yeah but
many of you were those were good times I
mean [ __ ] was pretty chill yeah they
were real good times in general people
were happy
[ __ ] was pretty chill in the 90s
um yeah so as I mentioned
um
okay so at this point they start talking
him and Terry nickels start talking
about we're gonna blow up a federal
building
uh 40a who was the meth head
he's like yeah I'm out that's that's
like a little too too much for me now he
did tell his wife about what they were
planning to do though
so basically like I said they were
hiding it because Timothy mcveilic wrote
a couple letters to ATF
um you know and basically just saying
hey we're coming for you kind of uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] so there was
that so like I said they were hiding it
so uh as we mentioned he initially
planned that they were going to do the
go the individual assassination route uh
Lon horayuchi who we mentioned before
like the sniper from Ruby Ridge he was
one of the ones that was on the list uh
Jane Arena was on the list obviously
um there was also a judge Walter Smith
Jr uh who was the guy on the Branch
Davidian trial
uh so you know he had like a list of
people he was like thinking about
assassinating
but
um it just I guess he felt like it was
just be too difficult
um you know to go and assassinate people
one by one
so he's like well it'd just be easier to
like knock him a bunch of them out once
so we'll go somewhere where a bunch of
them are and then we'll just like blow
it up and like you know so I kind of
feel like he was gonna do that this is a
dude that has a military background he
should know better but
foreign
direct kinetic action really is very
limited you know it could have been more
effective he just [ __ ] hired a bunch
of little kids eight nine-year-old kids
to just handcuff themselves at a big
long stream up around that building and
make a big steak you know what I mean
non-violent [ __ ] that would like [ __ ]
Gandhi would do you know we're not
moving you got to arrest us all that
would have been a lot far more effective
I mean that is a lot more effective
that's all you got yeah you know do some
you you want to do some crybaby [ __ ] you
want a bunch of kids out there crying
you know
well because like I said if you want
people to listen to your message yeah
blowing up a bunch of babies is not the
way you do it because you're just
immediately people you can't get past
that yeah they just blew up a bunch of
babies yeah they're gonna turn on you so
everybody's like we don't even if like
even if you have a point we're not gonna
listen to what you have to say now
because you blew up a bunch of babies
it's not instinctive for a soldier to
think that way where you know let's get
a bunch of little kids and handcuff them
together and we'll handcuff ourselves to
the door and cover ourselves in Blood
and cry and scream because that comes
off as kind of like weak weak looking
you know what I mean so they didn't go
to that but that would have been far
more well a lot more people would be
sympathetic to your cause if you did
that rather than just like killing
innocent he's [ __ ] people he's not a
civilian so he can't think that way but
uh you know I understand he he should
have done it my way get a bunch of
little kids and [ __ ] scream and cry
and kick and put on a big [ __ ] show
and get the [ __ ] on video and then get
photographs of yourselves being arrested
and make the [ __ ] government look
like bad guys and make everybody look
like meanies and that that's how you get
them you know that's far more effective
yeah instead of just blowing some [ __ ]
up and I mean Ben makes the point he's
like the government blew up all his
children at the Branch Davidian Church
yeah they did and that's what and that's
why and that's what's shitty because
it's like yeah that was shitty too
that's why but him doing the same thing
again doesn't make what he what he did
like better you've now you've never now
you've done two shitty things good job
now you've given now you've given the
morality back to the [ __ ] federal
government that's your enemy you want
them to stay the murderers
that's what I was saying get your kids
down there and dress them up with blood
and like they're burned up like they
burned up I mean there's something to be
said for taking the hive road yeah
because at least you have the moral High
Ground you can say well you guys blew up
kids like a Waco or whatever it's like
we would never do that make yourself the
good guys if you do the same thing as
them then you're as bad as they are and
they're what you're complaining about
for some reason these guys can't think
they're just as bad as they are then
you're thinking paramilit in a
paramilitary fashion like Tit for Tat
equal you know is what is what they're
right but that's not how you do it no
because the audience is a bunch of
civilians so you try to play up to them
and a bunch of lawyers and you also want
you want it so you cannot be prosecuted
or you're not prosecuted for anything
serious so you can come out and do it
again and again and again yeah so that
so you just
it doesn't matter if you win battles or
fire fights all right what matters if
you win Wars and Wars are about
endurance who endures who can last the
longest and if you're in prison you
haven't lost it
or if you get killed you haven't lasted
you just keep [ __ ] with them and
[ __ ] with them yeah [ __ ] with them
they're [ __ ] with them yeah they
throw you in jail but they can only hold
you for 12 hours because you haven't
committed because you haven't really
done anything he's doing it you keep
doing it you keep doing it you just you
have to have patience it's a long game
right yeah I mean if that's really what
your what Your angle is I kind of feel
like the problem with a lot of these
type of dudes is like they even if they
have legitimate points which I'm not
even saying if they do or don't I'm just
saying whatever their point is or
whatever their end game is they don't
have the patience to like stick it out
until the end or the training
that's not that's not that fight he's
the wrong fight yeah wrong fight he
should have been up there being a
crybaby and just put a big old [ __ ]
and protester and chain himself to the
door he would have got a lot more yeah
you just keep doing public sympathy yeah
yeah right and if you have public
sympathy on your side then you'll
immediately have like a bunch of other
people who will go to bat for you yeah
you blow up a bunch of babies No One's
Gonna Go to bat for you right so
you know whether you had a point or not
like nobody can hear you overweight you
don't want a bunch of grown men out
there you want women and children out
there
you're gonna be [ __ ] protested and
local college kids and [ __ ] like that
you want them to do it for you you put a
bunch of [ __ ] ex-military [ __ ]
veterans looking all right wing out of
their [ __ ] crying nobody's gonna buy
that you want [ __ ] weak people out
there or what will you consider they'll
be sympathetic to that oh my God you're
so oppressive you know I mean that
that's how you do it okay that's how
they do it that that's why they do what
they do if you look at protesters
you know they're never gonna have to do
like me out there protest
nobody nobody would buy it nobody's
gonna feel sorry for me
well yeah that's what I mean you know
people would be expecting me to see me
in riot gear with a cop or some [ __ ]
that's what they would cultural that
would be the expectation you know what I
mean so I understand why they are you
all are just mortal people you don't you
know you guys just do what you do you
know
I'm not moral no I'm not you're not look
at look at [ __ ] murder Hornets is in
there yeah okay back how to get a
Walgreens next to get some bread gonna
test out my new sandwich maker I know I
gotta I gotta like I bought some bagels
yesterday so I could have them in our
new toaster yeah but I haven't made one
yet I got cream cheese and everything
over at Dollar General
all right so uh so where was I yeah so
they decided not to do the
assassinations they're gonna go ahead
with the bombing so uh so yeah they
crafted a very large info explosive and
mounted it in the back of a rented Ryder
truck five thousand pounds
uh this this bomb was of ammonium
nitrate and nitromethane is what the
bomb was made of so five thousand pounds
in the back of the jar
so April 19th 1995. Timothy McVeigh
drives the rental truck
to the front of the Alfred P Murrah
Federal Building uh in Oklahoma City
at about well it's a little bit before
the office is open for the day they
opened at 9am
so before he gets there he Parks it out
front and uh he has a two minute fuse so
he lit the two minute fuse um you know
at 9am so the bomb went off at 9.02.
now the explosion uh and you know if you
Google it you can see the pictures it
took out
pretty much the front I mean it just
like obliterated
um probably like a third or two-thirds
of the building it just like took off
the whole like front of it
um ended up killing
168 people including 19 children that
were in the daycare center on the second
floor uh the youngest of those I think
was a baby like four months old
684 people also injured and 300 other
buildings around that building also
damaged I'm assuming most of that was
probably like broken windows and things
like that
as I mentioned earlier uh Timothy
McVeigh said oh I didn't know that there
was a daycare center in the second floor
um I might have like picked a different
place if I'd known that as I said I'm
not really sure I believe that because
he said that later on Terry Nichols
actually came out and said yeah we knew
there was a daycare center there and we
didn't give a [ __ ]
um and also from I've heard a couple of
sources that said
that they had actually toured the
building because I guess it was a
federal building so you could do a tour
of it you know what I mean and they had
actually done a tour of it like sometime
before they had actually bombed it so
they were absolutely familiar with what
all the [ __ ] was in there
so
um basically this is what he said so
um he had some biographers that were
like writing a book about him
and they did like a bunch of interviews
with him he never did by the way
um you know express any kind of remorse
of any kind uh for anything that he did
um you know he just he just didn't I
mean he wasn't sorry
one of the things that he said
and this is kind of going back to what
you said earlier like how he would
justify it he says to these people in
Oklahoma who have lost a loved one I'm
sorry but it happens every day you're
not the first mother to lose a kid or
the first grandparent to lose a grandson
or a granddaughter it happens every day
somewhere in the world I'm not going to
go into that courtroom curl into a fetal
ball and cry just because the victims
want me to do that that's what he said
that he's like oh it's okay because
people die every day so you know that's
not quite what he said but I mean that's
kind of what he said that's the gist
he's saying people die all the time
[ __ ] suck it up that's what yeah I
always kind of Wonder I was wondering
this before because I mean like I said
he had a little bit of an incel Vibe too
um did he never really had a girlfriend
or anything and I kind of wonder if he'd
had like a wife and a kid would he have
done the same thing would he have felt
the same because maybe then he could
have taken himself out of his own shoes
and be like what if that was my wife
what if that was my kid you know would
he have had more empathy or no maybe
it's possible wait he would have had he
wouldn't have wanted he wouldn't have
been so self-sacrificing
what would have happened he's like yeah
that shit's bad what what that what the
ATF did to wake up that's not my problem
I got to take care of My Wife and Kids
would have been like that probably
yeah and I mean I think he specifically
said in one of the um
he had Kamikaze mentality he did yeah I
don't really think he didn't seem like
he wasn't a very happy person he wasn't
a very fulfilled person he just seemed
like a very very angry bitter person and
like he and he wasn't that old I mean
you know what I mean he was still like
in his 20s when he did this right so it
just kind of felt like
yeah I don't really think he saw any
kind of like future and this was like
the way he was gonna go I think he saw
himself as a patriot as yeah patriotic
he did and that he was saving the
country from a from a from a from a
burgeoning totalitarian regime that was
trying to take over and he was trying to
stop it early that's what I think he
thought yeah yeah that's right he was
from what I saw of what he said he was
willing to die for this because in and
he's not lying you know he he [ __ ]
serves a deer at a time of War so he
thought he was helping the American
people in the grand scheme of things
the thing is though is he's looking at
this from a very naive point of
perspective okay that was a losing
strategy that mission wasn't worth it
he killed all those people and then got
himself killed
over something that didn't over a
mission that didn't make a difference
not a positive difference that didn't
help us cause
he should have just protested
yeah like I said which like I said it
would take a lot worse it takes longer
for sure but he would have had more time
but yeah he'd have more time because
yeah you're going to get arrested if you
do this and that but he hasn't committed
a serious crimes he's going to be out 12
hours later
might be trespassing or something
and uh
he should have gotten all that [ __ ] on
video you know and tried to get it
played there was no distribution back
then
yeah that's another thing so but you
still could have
caused enough stink where somebody would
have eventually covered it I think
um especially if it was just like a big
scale protest
which he could have if they could build
all those bombs they could have done a
big skill protest yeah yeah they were
they were just expending their energies
probably in the wrong area yeah it's an
inefficient way of doing it I would have
just [ __ ] protested and pestered him
and harassed and pestered and [ __ ] um
uh
sold videos of me protesting it at gun
shows you know that kind of [ __ ] he
could have made money on the side
here's [ __ ] look man
1999 I'll give you [ __ ] two hours of
me trolling the ATF it's hilarious you
know
I mean much easier nowadays should be
fair but you know nowadays if you could
you could [ __ ] sell it but he could
have sold that [ __ ] at gun shows people
probably would have bought it yeah they
probably would especially if he was
funny
yeah think of think how angry gay Pope
we've had him on the show
him troll in Scientology he was
hilarious I would just watch his show if
before the internet and had somebody
said look man [ __ ] 1999 1995 this
video two hours of this guy just
trolling this cult that's hilarious and
and I saw a sample I might buy something
like that and watch it especially if
there was this and once you watch one
I'd probably bought more of them yeah
you know I would have done something
like that so you sent a sense of humor
ridiculed When people's heart I mean
people love funny [ __ ] everybody loves
funny [ __ ]
so much okay you gotta [ __ ] apply
this to other things
I think
the most damaging thing really that ever
happened
to The Cult of Scientology
was that [ __ ] South Park South Park I
was gonna say
because it was true and it was funny as
[ __ ]
and I think that was that spelled the
end of Scientology
as a as a business
just that little show I mean that wasn't
the only thing but I think that was a
pretty big uh part of it that brought it
to the Public's attention the mainstream
of public content it was [ __ ]
hilarious
and they weren't lying that's another
thing like all the [ __ ] they said in
there was true this is exactly what this
is this really what Scientology believes
the UFO cult the [ __ ] scene so in a
lot of ways let's like even though South
Park is just like you know from from a
in the grand scheme of thing it's just
like kind of a dumb cartoon show but it
actually had a really really large
cultural impact and probably a positive
impact too because it got like more
people looking into it and more people
being like [ __ ] that [ __ ] you know what
I mean yeah so I think that was like
that was a really good thing for society
as well
these dudes uh McNichols and uh Nichols
Terry Nichols and McVeigh
short-sighted they were not far-thinking
guys
had they waited a couple more years
AJ and the written in His Radio Show
would have been around they could have
been guests on that and then [ __ ]
YouTube primitive YouTube would have
been out just a decade later
not even that really
yeah YouTube actually I came out what
2000 2006 I want to say yeah the decade
later you'd had YouTube and and all his
material could have been up on that and
uh he would wouldn't have been a a
criminal you know his his uh reputation
would have been totally different
so it was too hasty man and they're not
thinking this is not three third
three-dimensional thinking this is
two-dimensional thinking what they're
doing just dumb
that's not how you do retro [ __ ] you
know
yeah just uh
they just waited and played the long
game
they could have [ __ ] probably made a
living off of [ __ ]
protest in ATF
well yeah I mean they had like a fan
base I mean yeah well I mean he was
known like kind of on the gun show
circuit and stuff like that like he
sells his old stuff and he had boots and
stuff so like people knew who he was it
had been far more I don't think he
wasn't famous or nothing like that could
have been later on yeah but I'm just
saying that like out that's even at the
time back then like he was kind of like
in the scene like people saw him around
you know yeah you got to play the long
game in in all wars war is the long gram
it's not as you see all civilians have
figured out Warfare is not shock and awe
how many times did my Army [ __ ] pull
shock and awe out and it didn't change a
[ __ ] thing it's never resolved in
some big [ __ ] spectacular event it's
always the long game yeah well see I
kind of feel like people maybe think
that just because well that's what makes
the more exciting movies yeah but it's
like really it's just like boring [ __ ]
yeah that makes the most yeah existence
long-term kind of boring stuff that
makes the most difference
it's only on television that very very
rarely happens very rarely happens
so uh so yeah so after they did uh the
bombing
what ended up happening was that in the
rubble they found uh the rear axle of
the rider rental truck now remember the
old Axel story and it had the V the VIN
number on it yeah
so uh the FBI were able to track this uh
rental truck back to where it had been
rented which was in Junction City Kansas
so uh the workers at the you know Rider
rental agency they remembered what the
guy that rented it looked like because
it had only been like the day before so
they got with the FBI sketch artist they
did a sketch which actually if you see
the sketch and then put it right next to
like Tim McVeigh it's actually a pretty
good sketch they did a good job like it
actually does really look like him now
uh Timothy McVeigh was you know was kind
of a dummy but not that much of a dummy
he did actually use a fake name when he
rented the truck and that fake name was
Robert Kling he actually had a fake
driver's license and everything
so they showed the sketch around town
and uh somebody that managed the local
Motel where Timothy McVeigh been staying
identified him it's like oh yeah that
was a guy that was staying here
now interestingly uh not too long after
the bombing
uh Timothy McVeigh was driving uh near
Perry Oklahoma and he got pulled over by
a State Trooper named Charles hanger
now uh he got pulled over because he was
speeding and also because his car which
was a 1977 Mercury Marquis hadn't uh
didn't have a license plate
so basically uh McVeigh gets out of the
car and the trooper sees like a ball
generous jacket and a suit and uh you
know Timothy McVeigh is like yeah I got
a gun and uh the cops like uh yeah I got
a gun too you know what I mean kind of
uh situation
so uh basically he got arrested Timothy
McVeigh got arrested for uh driving
without plates obviously and for having
a an illegal firearm because he didn't
have the uh you know the papers for it
or anything like that uh because he
didn't have um he had a concealed weapon
but it was like fake you know what I
mean
or it wasn't legal in that state or
whatever it was
so um so he got arrested for that
and then they didn't know that he was
the guy that had done the bombing like
the state trooper that arrested him he
was just arrested him because he didn't
have a license plate and because he had
like a concealed weapon the weapon that
it wasn't legal for him to be carrying
um and then later on they found out that
oh my God that's the guy that actually
did the bombing you know what I mean now
because when the bombing first happened
and I remember when it first happened
too because I was in my early 20s I was
like 23 I think when this happened
um and I remember everybody immediately
thinking it was like Islamic terrorists
and people being like kind of surprised
like when they found out that it was
just that it was the guy who it was you
know what I mean
not everybody was but a lot of people
weren't because like I said we'd had
like uh the World Trade Center bombing
not 911 obviously but the one that
happened in 1993 where they just blew up
didn't they just blow up like it was
like in the parking garage or like the
bay the like the lower levels right
what's that that the First World Trade
Center bombing yeah it was the one that
was in the lower levels yeah and it
didn't even [ __ ] do anything to the
building not really it didn't like do
that much of a damage but yeah I mean it
was a big deal at the time but that was
like Islamic terrorists so everybody was
like thinking along those lines so
everybody was like really surprised that
it wasn't that because I kind of feel
like when they caught the guy they were
just kind of like oh well that's not
what we were expecting so there's that
so he gets hauled in uh he's indicted on
11 counts uh conspiracy to use a weapon
of mass destruction use of a weapon of
mass destruction uh destruction with use
of explosives eight counts of first
degree murder that was just for the
deaths of the law enforcement officers I
see other people don't count uh but yeah
so um basically they had to do a change
of venue so they actually moved it from
Oklahoma City to Denver because I guess
they were assuming that he couldn't get
a fair trial in Oklahoma City because
everyone was a little bit mad
understandably
so uh basically what they wanted to do I
guess he wanted them to do
what they call a necessity defense
he wanted to argue they said well we
know we couldn't argue Insanity because
he was obviously very very sane and very
intelligent and was not
you know he he had reasons for doing
what he was doing and he was very
articulate about saying what those were
so you know they're like we couldn't do
that
so he wanted to do
he wanted to basically say well not
self-defense but he's like I felt like I
was in imminent danger from the
government so I was retaliating that's
kind of like what so almost like
self-defense I kind of like feel like
that was the route that he wanted to go
um his argument was that imminent danger
doesn't necessarily mean like immediate
danger like you know what I mean like I
thought they were gonna come get me
that's kind of what
that's kind of what he was so he was
trying to justify that he had like
bombed the building because of
like because it was a reasonable
response to like what had happened at
Waco and what had happened at Ruby Ridge
right yeah so that's what he was trying
to argue
um it didn't work spoiler alert
1997 uh he was found guilty on all 11
counts
um so like I said even though 168 people
in total were killed uh the only murder
charges brought against him were for the
eight uh federal agents who were on duty
and were killed during the thing I don't
know why that was but you know what I
mean that's what they did
so uh basically he's like
uh so he gets sentenced to death
actually
Terry Nichols uh was also
arrested and convicted although he got a
life
sentence so he didn't get executed
but the thing about it though was that
interestingly they they pretty much I
don't know if they expedited it but they
did the death penalty because he was
convicted in what 97 and then they
executed him in 2001 which is like
pretty quick like he did an appeal and
stuff like that but
you know what I mean they were trying to
get rid of him as soon as possible yeah
and they want him to get the followers I
think that's what that was all about
well and he he actually asked he wanted
his execution to be televised nationally
but
um you were like no but they were like
yeah now
um although there was an unnamed
internet company that they actually sued
for the right to broadcast it like the
execution but they didn't win
um so he was actually like on the same
uh kind of they call the bombers row he
was on there with like Ted Kaczynski and
all those kind of guys yeah they're high
fives romsey Youssef and all that yeah
he was trying to convert him to Islam
that didn't work out it didn't work yeah
no well McVeigh was he later said he was
an agnostic but he actually took the
Catholic last rates I think he was like
raised as an Irish Catholic yeah he said
he wasn't religious but they said that
he was kind of like going a little bit
that way toward the end but yeah it was
like kind of funny though I feel like
the [ __ ] bombers like trying to
convert each other to their own [ __ ]
religions like in [ __ ] prison Jesus
Christ
uh high five in each other you did a
good job yes they probably were which is
like really [ __ ] up because the thing
about it was that when they executed
um Timothy McVeigh like I said like so
many members of the public like wanted
to come in and see him die that they had
to do a lottery because they couldn't
fit everybody yeah
um but he didn't
they asked him if he had any last words
he had like some kind of poem
that he wanted said but other than that
they asked if you have anything else and
he just wouldn't say anything and
Hickory Dickory Dock stick was sucking
my [ __ ] Andrew Dice Clay Paul oh God I
remember that
whatever happened to that [ __ ] I
got old well you don't but I mean just
like I wonder what happened to him like
okay he did a couple movies and then he
didn't want to do that character anymore
and then people ignored him he tried to
be funny without that character and
people were like nope yeah you're only
funny you're only funny characters go
away please yeah
yeah and that character wasn't that
funny I went back and saw it kind of
[ __ ] he really wasn't I was funny I
don't even think he was that funny back
then but it's it's not really my style
of Comedy like I I was real into like
stand-up comedy in the 90s but I kind of
like comedians that just I don't like so
much comedians that just like tell jokes
like set up punchline kind of like a
very obvious kind of joke I like
comedians that just like tell kind of
rambling stories that just happen to be
funny like uh [ __ ] uh red foxes like
that and [ __ ] so it was uh [ __ ]
Buddy Hackett I'm trying to think of
like a lot of comedians I liked in the
90s like I love Eddie Izzard I love
um I really liked Jake Johansen whatever
happened to him he was like funny as
hell that Jewish dude was [ __ ]
hilarious what was that which one
I don't know who you're talking about
I forgot his name you guys remember you
guys he goes
you say you look like a hooker you say a
woman looks like a hooker she'll get mad
at you but it's a compliment
there actually people have to pay you
know tell the Jewish woman she looks at
her and she goes thank you it just went
to funny what was that guy's name
you guys in the comment section know
what I'm talking about during the 90s he
was big in the 80s and the 90s do this
[ __ ] layer it wasn't milk it wasn't
[ __ ] Mel Brooks
American Military 100 said Richard Pryor
was a Storyteller too oh yeah yeah yeah
see I tend to like comedians that are
more like that I don't so much like I
mean I've seen comedians that were just
like set up punchline that were funny
but I tend to like ones that just like
tell funny stories like rather than it
being like structured you know what I
mean yeah
um
let's see what was up here I think I
missed some stuff Jones Perkins said my
wife kept me from going crazy I'll tell
you that people were marked about a year
after getting with her that I was not
the same person
and uh she replaced me with a better
version of myself yeah see I was kind of
wondering about that that was just
something that I randomly thought
because I kind of think about that
when I read about these kind of guys or
serial killers or whoever I'm just like
you know what circumstances could have
been different that like the outcome
would have been different you know what
I mean and I just kind of wonder about
Timothy McVeigh like if he had
God if he had finished college for
example or if he had you know gotten a
girlfriend or gotten married and like
had a kid or something like that like
would he have gone down this right he
might still have because you know people
like that do that all the time and [ __ ]
they're serial killers that have wives
and kids too so it's that doesn't
preclude like you going down that path
but I'm just kind of wondering like in
the context of the situation like if it
would have worked out the same if it
would have worked out the same
um I don't know why I thought this was
interesting I'm always like really
interested in
um people's last meals like before they
get executed I don't know why that
fascinates me so much because I'm just
like you're gonna die like what it what
is the last thing you want to eat you
know what I mean because I'm like oh my
God what would I pick I don't know if
I'd be able to pick no it wasn't Lenny
Bruce it was what was his name Jackie uh
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny
man Jackie Mason
do you guys want to see some funny [ __ ]
man look at Jackie Mason dude yeah I
remember that guy yeah he's hilarious
but Timothy mcveigh's uh last meal was
two pints of mint chocolate chip ice
cream
okay yeah I'd eat that too
for your last meal though yeah I mean I
love mint chocolate chip ice cream don't
get me wrong that's probably what you
wanted that's probably my favorite
flavor
which [ __ ] man now I have the same
favorite ice cream flavor is Timothy
McVeigh funniest one that I [ __ ]
heard as they were they were executing
this uh they were gonna execute this one
dude uh he was uh mentally [ __ ]
mentally handicapped black dude he'd
killed some women or so accused of it
and uh he had his last supper and he
[ __ ] saves the dessert it's aren't
you eat dessert and he and he goes no
I'll eat it afterwards
and then okay then he took him to go
[ __ ] get
you shouldn't be executing people that
are mental yeah he was though
handicapped like that yeah I'm just
saying that they shouldn't be I remember
when they were talking about that he
said he would think he had like a
chocolate sundae or something and they
said aren't you gonna eat aren't you
gonna eat your dessert and he's like
I'll have it afterwards and they were
like okay and then I guess well he
didn't realize so I guess he couldn't
fully comprehend it
yeah
spooky when you think about it it is but
I mean I guess like maybe
I guess it was better for him because he
didn't actually know he really didn't
really know what was going on but that's
still [ __ ] up they shouldn't be doing
it yeah
Jones Perkins said this comment will
make you feel old if you read it when
the bombing happened I was in fourth
grade and I remember it very well I
believe I was nine years old yeah I
think I was
I was 23. I was 23. I was out of the
army what was this 96 I think 95 95 yeah
I was out of the army yeah I graduated
from high school in 1990 so I was
yeah I was in college
but
yeah
I was 23 yeah 23. I was in college
uh but yeah so as I mentioned earlier uh
Timothy McVeigh was executed in 2001
and uh they said that when he was uh
executed that he just had a completely
Blank Stare
and he never expressed any remorse for
anything that he did or nothing like
that and like I said a lot of the um you
know family the victims were there like
when he got executed as well
so you know what I mean and um he they
wouldn't let him be buried in a military
cemetery
so they actually uh cremated him but
nobody knows like what they did with his
ashes the ashes they gave him to his
lawyer do it in the pot probably yeah
put him in the fish tank
something like kill a fish
[ __ ] gross they kind of thought um
they thought maybe like he said I guess
Timothy McVeigh was like oh maybe you
can scatter him like where the building
was and everybody's like no we're not
[ __ ] doing that
just Jesus Christ the [ __ ] are you
thinking so yeah they're not doing that
um so there was that
so I you know I don't know this this is
a [ __ ] up story and I'm kind of
bumming myself out no just from a serial
killer [ __ ] the toolbox murderers well I
know that like that bums me out too like
all this kind of [ __ ] bums me out this
is almost kind of like something from
wartime just explosion kills a bunch of
people yeah well let's make it feel
better it's still sad it wasn't torture
though and it didn't have a sexual
element to it where there's some
innocent people were picked out to be
[ __ ] sexual targets from some [ __ ]
mad man it wasn't like this this is more
kind of just like a random
[ __ ]
almost like a [ __ ] natural disaster
in a certain way these dude these dudes
thought what they were doing I think was
I think they thought what they were
doing was the right thing in the big
picture well they seemed so didn't they
but they no [ __ ] no they're [ __ ]
that's the wrong [ __ ] tactics to use
you know where's your [ __ ] strategy
[ __ ] to win a war is a long haul the
last thing you want to do is to [ __ ]
get yourself locked up into a prison or
get killed no did I just dumb dumb it's
it's funny how intelligent guys can be
so dumb
but for some reason they thought because
of that book they thought that they
needed some kind of high profile attack
that was real flashy they would make it
onto the news so they would get news
media coverage
you don't need that either and had they
you just need time and had they [ __ ]
been patient you had YouTube and the
internet
and then they could have just [ __ ]
disseminated information and their point
of views and they could have [ __ ] uh
said you know told the stories of
[ __ ] how the Waco thing went down and
how it was [ __ ] the wrong thing to do
and
um that it was handled poorly and then
the whole [ __ ]
Ruby Ridge thing where they shoot a
dude's [ __ ] wife you know really in
the dog really for nothing you know
um
there's a lot of ammunition you could
use in an information War right there
you know and they
the kinetic attack
that's the last thing you'd want to do
yeah their thinking is just [ __ ] up
you know real [ __ ]
super conventional and retro and out of
date I don't even think that would have
worked in the 20s
now
no not at all that wouldn't have worked
in the 20s every successful Revolution
wasn't like that
you know look how the Bolsheviks did it
they did it by taking over the damn
train set the train system of Russia
everything went through Moscow if you
ran if you ran that Moscow [ __ ] train
[ __ ] station and you ran the whole
country because you could send soldiers
and supplies everywhere you wanted
um American Revolution [ __ ] took
[ __ ] 20 years all right and [ __ ] a
bunch of people they didn't just declare
independence and it was over you know no
that [ __ ] wasn't resolved until the war
of 1812. you know so
very limited understanding of human of
human conflict and history
too much Hollywood
high profile attack backfired autumn
dumb
Sly says uh I like what people say on
their Death Beds
like either these curtains go where I do
you said Lord Byron I thought that was
Oscar Wilde but I could be wrong uh Ali
McNair says hi you two on a happier note
Happy New Year I hope Pookie got the
treats I sent her from Chewie oh it was
you that's Adam okay thank you very much
yes we did get those who was this again
Ally Ally okay thank you very much for
those she is she loves those as soon as
I brought the Box up she was like she
knew she knows she knows that she knew
it was for her she could probably smell
them she knows that packaging she loves
when she loves those things coming out
she goes retreats
yes she knows what flavor they are about
what color they are yeah she sees that
turquoise she goes like Oh that's tuna
that's the good one that's the good ones
yeah she sees the red ones she's like oh
that's salmon yeah the same ones are
pink like she'll eat the chicken ones
which I think are kind of yellowish
right yeah orange or orange it's an
orange little orange [ __ ] stripe on
it on a black on a brown package
those ones are kind of those ones are
okay yeah like she'll eat the salmon
ones but she's kind of like like she's
very allergic about it
um but yeah so what's what I had oh I
had some notes about uh Turner Diaries
but yeah we already kind of talked about
that yeah it's just um
yeah it's a violent revolution that's uh
a nuclear war and a race war yeah and
the end of it is a systematic
extermination of non-whites yeah the guy
at the it's like I said it's a fictional
novel but the guy's name is Earl Turner
hence the Turner Diaries and he wants to
kill Jews non-whites liberal actors and
politicians yeah he's trying to all get
murdered he's tripping that's like
something from some kind of sideways
[ __ ] Hollywood movie that's not how
reality works
you know and I thought this was
interesting too because this book Not
only was it uh the impetus for this
bombing but uh also for the 1999 nail
bombings that happened in London and
also do you guys remember this the
assassination of Alan Berg the radio
talk show host the liberal uh atheist uh
radio talk show host they made a movie
about it with Eric bagozian called Talk
Radio I think that was actually really
good if you haven't seen it but um that
happened in 1984 he got killed by uh
Aryan Nation like skinheads yeah
race riot that Revolution is [ __ ]
fantasy those guys are fantasizing
usually if you look at history
there have been race there's been racial
Wars but that usually takes place if you
look at the detail in pla in countries
that are very small
if they haven't happened in the United
States it would have been a local event
not Nationwide okay
um
mostly revolutions are mainstream a
successful revolutions are they're
mainstream they involve everybody the
entire population race usually isn't a
factor usually the main factor is
economy money and living standards go
away so people [ __ ] rise up because
the government no longer serves them
so it's not just it's not this [ __ ]
where your white people wouldn't [ __ ]
wipe it out now it's it's everybody
rising up against the [ __ ]
non-functional government that's usually
how it goes
and it's not apocalyptic either usually
once it's over it kind of normalizes
within a few months after that because a
new regimes get in
American Military 100 said I love talk
radio it was such a good movie I haven't
seen it a long time but I remember
really liking it uh totally forgot about
that movie I didn't know it was based on
a true story yeah I'm pretty sure if I
remember correctly I'm pretty sure it
was based on the assassination of Alan
Berg which happened in the 80s
um yeah he was killed because by uh
neo-nazis because he was uh Jewish and
he was outspoken about his atheism and
about his liberalism on the air and uh
neo-nazis didn't like it so they came
and shot him in the I think it was in
the parking lot it was back in the 80s
one early 84. 84. 84 that was
um yeah it was it was pretty [ __ ] up
but it's a good movie though but yeah so
uh let me see so remember the the 48 guy
the the meth head yeah so him and his
wife uh they were also considered
accomplices because they knew about it
they weren't involved directly but they
knew about it beforehand uh so uh they
actually kind of got um oh and also the
wife had helped uh Timothy McVeigh with
the fake driver's license that he had
used to rent the truck
so um 48 actually got off a little bit
because he agreed to testify against
Timothy McVeigh and Terry Nichols uh in
exchange for a reduced sentence uh and
his wife got immunity like in that deal
so he got 12 years and fined 75
000 uh but he got released a little bit
earlier like he got released in 2006 for
good behavior and went into the witness
protection program
so there was that
um a couple of other things I think
somebody mentioned I think Camp guy
mentioned like very early on in the show
about
uh the third person or whatever now
there was like come some kind of stuff
that there was like a John Doe number
two because there was another like
apparently like some of the workers at
the Ryder Rental truck place had
described another dude that like came in
and rented a truck and they did a um a
drawing of him so for a long time they
thought maybe this was another
conspirator so they were looking for
that person but I think what they
figured out later on was that that was
like a completely innocent dude who
would just come into the place to rent a
truck like the day before and they just
got the days mixed up you know what I
mean like you would do like you didn't
realize that it was like a different day
or whatever so they figured out who that
dude was and he didn't have anything to
do with Timothy McVeigh he just happened
to like rent a Raider truck like the day
before and they just happened to
remember him you know what I mean um
there's also been some rumors and nobody
knows
I don't think anybody knows how much of
this is true but that Timothy McVeigh
was involved with the Christian identity
movement uh some people said that they
had seen him at some of the little
private meetings or whatever that they
had so I don't know how much of that is
true or not because like I said he did
claim later on that he wasn't religious
or that he was agnostic but I have seen
like some people like Christian identity
was kind of like Nazi
yeah I think essentially
um some there there are some witnesses
that said that they saw him in those
areas or they know that he was in those
areas at around the time that they knew
that there was like meetings of that
going on and some people did say that
they'd seen him probably [ __ ] though
but I don't know I don't know
um I mean well their beliefs did kind of
align in a lot of ways but that I mean
some people said that they saw him like
associating with the with that group but
I don't know maybe went and checked it
out or something that's yeah I don't
think that he was like the thing about
him is that I mean his psychology yeah
he had a couple of like conspirators and
stuff but he wasn't it wasn't like a
real organized he he was very much like
a lone wolf type of
actor
like he had a specific agenda and he had
like other people that were helping him
like push this agenda but he mostly just
it was mostly just like a handful of
people it wasn't like it was an
organized movement in to any like to any
great degree I guess you know what I
mean
Ben says they went to the um Elohim City
FBI skinhead Church please yeah that's
kind of that's what I heard I was like
watching one of the documentaries about
that early on
but yeah even though he even though
McVeigh wasn't religious he was more
closely related in terms of like just
character and ideology and just the
character of way he was
had he been Christian he would have been
one of these I'm going to stop the mark
of the beast kind of guys yeah that
they're going to come and take over and
they're gonna wipe out the Christians
and um you know I'm gonna stop the
market of Beast that he was
even yeah that's what that's what I
meant that was a dude like that yeah
even though he was secular he was trying
to he saw himself
as a Hero trying to stop a [ __ ]
totalitarian government taking over and
[ __ ] um taking everybody's guns and
that they were going after Christian
groups first and they would gotten away
with rake Waco and that uh he wasn't
gonna let him get away with it and that
he was going to show
the American population that you could
fight them and if you fight them then
they'll run and then uh we'll straighten
it out and we'll win and and I'll go
down in history as a revolutionary hero
you know after my death he was one of
those kind of guys yeah
um but no it was a miscalculation this
is this is uh the fantasies of a young
man that's not how things actually work
you know and that's not how revolutions
work and that's not how [ __ ] that's
not how you fight
any kind of uh entrenched
institution it takes a long time and
usually violence is not what you want
that's not what you want
uh propaganda is what you want or
um lawyers you know legal attacks and
[ __ ] propaganda attacks to try to get
to change public opinion
to get them defunded that kind of stuff
that's that's how you do it
it's a lot easier and you're not
breaking any laws
yeah I mean you know and you're not
killing innocent people that didn't have
yeah [ __ ] all to do with whatever you
were mad at yeah I mean besides
mentioning [ __ ] French Revolution
yeah
that's the that's one way it can go but
that actually is the hard way the easy
way is what happened in the Soviet Union
it's there one minute and a day later
it's just gone poof
because people don't want to show up to
work for it they no longer believe in it
all right
and they go that way too just the
government's there and then a couple
days later it's Army's gone the
bureaucracy is gone nobody believes in
it it's money is gone the banks are gone
just overnight I'll watch that [ __ ]
happen I was on duty when that should
happen we couldn't believe it it just
the Soviet Union we thought this thing
was just a megalithic Powerhouse we were
scared of this thing we were training to
fight it
and just in a matter of a few days it no
longer existed it just evaporated
without a shot fired
you know and they go that way too
yep it can happen yeah
all right so I guess we've been going
three hours
yeah and uh we got food to make man I
got yeah I'm pretty hungry well I was
just I was waiting for you to okay
quit talking
to me she's blaming me and it's
something it's a show she talks through
the whole show I didn't talk to the
whole show you wrote that through the
whole show okay I ain't gonna fight her
I know it's just I'll lose ground if I
sit here try to reason with her well and
then you'll just go on longer and longer
and then I'll get blamed for like making
it right like last long all right tell
you what Jim what you got anything you
need to plug or anything now I'm just
gonna I don't know shut that [ __ ] I mean
I guess I could just plug go to our
patreon and do that [ __ ] yeah we always
require more patrons like share
subscribe do all that stuff if you
haven't done that you guys mostly do
that I'm just saying just reminded
people in case they don't but uh yeah so
I guess that's it all right so uh we'll
be back Friday night
for the Side Tracks show uh so that
should be like more fun because we won't
be talking about terrorists I mean maybe
we'll probably end up talking about
terrorists anyway you know how we do uh
but yeah so it should be more fun and
more entertaining and it'll be New
Year's Eve Eve
so you know that'll be kind of exciting
because it's kind of like a holiday all
right so thank you everybody for
dropping by and hanging out with us this
evening and thank you for your super
chats and all of the discussion and
we'll see you guys again on Friday night
good night
thank you
foreign